so Donald Trump waves to people a
picture is taken he has golf blisters on
his hand and now the media is a wash
with conspiracies that he's got syphilis
or perhaps the clap which I I don't
believe uh red marks on your hand is a
symptom of the clap nor do I think like
this is really funny cuz people are like
the news outlets are actually reporting
on this claiming at syphilis I'm like
dude they're golf blisters he went
golfing that like this is totally not
news but uh the talking point is and the
funny thing is if Trump actually had
syphilis and it had progressed to the
point where his hand is covered in in in
blisters all over his body this would
imply he's had syphilis for I think like
10 years and he's never taken an
antibiotic before so uh welcome to the
2024 election cycle where you got James
Carville com com in on how he thinks
Trump has the clap and this is their
this is going to be it they're they're
they're going to win by claiming Trump's
golf okay when you Golf and you and your
gloves aren't right or whatever you get
you get blisters it it happens all the
time you can go there's photos
everywhere it's really not surprising in
fact some Professor just came out right
outright when asked for comment by one
of these news organizations like they're
golf blisters but they're going to keep
running this story so we'll talk about
that plus man Democrats are actually
starting to panic cuz Donald Trump is
winning the youth vote not an
exaggeration
I almost don't want to believe it cuz I
think they're lying to us I think their
strategy is like hey you know how we're
always wrong and we underestimate Trump
in the polls let's overestimate him in
the polls get L him into a fall sense of
security but we even have Vox writing
that Democrats are panicking as they
lose the youth vote and uh more and more
Trump is gaining these young voters Teen
Vogue is even writing about it so we'll
talk about that plus we got some another
clip from Shan Strickland dude Shan
Strickland you're you're awesome you're
amazing I'm really excited to see your
fight he he's wearing wearing a shirt
that says make Canada great again he
shouts out to the people in the audience
that he's here to defend them their
rights their free speech this guy's a
warrior so I just say everybody should
watch this fight support UFC support
Strickland and and and what he's
standing up for he's a good dude and uh
and he's got balls but uh we will jump
into all that stuff before we get
started my friends head over to cast
brew.com if you want to purchase some of
the best coffee you've ever had I got to
say uh we were going over the numbers
the other day in sales Appalachia
Knights is a home run
the other coffee stuff the other coffee
stuff we we we do sell the the other
Blends rise with Roberto Jr you know
stand your grounds is also very popular
it seems like we sell these because we
shout them out you know people who like
the show and want to support us will buy
it but Appalachian kns it's like in in a
in a week or two we period we're selling
thousands of bags whereas the other ones
are doing hundreds really and I keep
hearing from people saying Appalachian
Knights really is the best coffee
they've ever had well I really do
appreciate appreciate it we uh basically
the way it works is um we received a
bunch of different samp a bunch of
different Origins and we came up with
what we thought was the best and what we
liked the most and in our crafting of
the blend Appalachian kns uh was one of
the ones we made and apparently people
really do love it so I recommend it but
don't forget we also got Alex Stein's
Prime Time grind two times caffeine we
got the new commercial with Alex Stein
up right now you can check it out it's
hilarious and uh casper.com if you want
to support the show but also head over
to
timcast.net show coming up for you
tonight at 10 p.m. it's going to be a
lot of fun and I must stress everything
we do is made possible because we have
members like you it's how it's How We F
this operation so if you want to watch
the uncensored show if you want to join
the Discord and hang out with
like-minded individuals to help build
culture that I really recommend become a
member but if you like the work we're
doing if you like the primary uh show
that we did in Iowa and if you want to
help us do more events coming up become
a member because your membership be it
only $10 a month it all adds up allows
us to budget effectively and build
culture and fight that culture War so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about this
and everything else Dom ler hey thanks
thanks for having me who are you what do
you do I'm a investigative journalist
just independent journalism mainly known
on X right on I hear you're the breaker
of narratives yeah that's what people
say all right people say so so you're
here we we'll uh we'll see what
narratives get broken yeah for sure I'm
definitely excited to break some all
right should be fun Hannah Clair is
hanging out hey I'm Hannah Clair bmla
I'm a writer for cnr.com I'm looking
forward to the show tonight and Libby's
here hey Han Clair hey how are you he
Tim hey D glad to be here I'm Libby
Emmons the editor with the post
millennial and uh glad to be on the show
yeah I'm filling in for Ian again he's
gone yeah and uh I am surge.com I'm
gonna adjust the brightness on Hannah's
camera really fast and Hannah's camera
real fast who Hannah clear scammer thank
goodness dang it I'm fired you are fired
you're immediately fired my last broom
cast ever all right let's go all right
here's the here's the big story of the
day the first thing I want to say uh you
know Trump let me read the title for you
Trump's red hand markings draw wild
speculation including syphilis
conspiracies and so here's the uh let's
open the image so you can get a better
VI I'm GNA be honest with everybody so
we're we're sitting here getting ready
for the show and I'm just like there
really is no news today and you know one
of the top stories on The Daily Mail is
like horses whole SUV from ditch and I
was
like what is this not news but man
they're really grasping and so the
people who hate Trump are running out of
things to hate Trump about so when Trump
waves and he's got blisters on his hands
which are clearly golf blisters there's
no other explanation I mean maybe he
felt fine whatever but you can look at
where they're at clearly from gripping a
golf club golf blisters are extremely
common these are the stories that they
decide to run could Donald Trump have
syphilis they say former president
Donald Trump was photographed Wednesday
leaving his Manhattan apartment with
Patchwork of red markings resembling
blisters on his right hand drawing Mass
speculation about the cause of the
apparent Affliction As Trump has stayed
uncharacteristically mum on the
subject what to say like well do you to
be not mum about do you think we'll ever
get to the point where we elect a
president that openly has syphilis I
mean that's my question are we just
taking away the St
for Trump to have had progressed in
syphilis to that degree it would mean
that he had symptoms for like 10 years
okay so or like so you don't think we'll
ever be like this President will be like
I have syphilis and I should lead the
country it is an entirely curable
disease I don't know what
if you can get some what is it like
antibiotics or something but I want to
say this is why people hate the media
and don't trust the media because this
is this is basically the lead story of
the day which is ridiculous it really is
looked like James Carville is talking
about it MSNBC is talking about it do
you think that's cuz people are La
though I feel like this is easier than
some of the other stuff that's going on
right now aliens are in their spaceship
above the Earth and they're about to
press the make first Contact button and
the story popped up and then the other
alien pushed the hand away and said
no not not not these people get behind
me Satan no these people are no good
we're we're eject and then they leave
we're not going to bring them into the
galactics Federation it said resembling
uh resembling bister say resembling kind
of funny yeah put it right there not
sure yeah just for it's it's funny the
way they play those tricks host of
msnbc's Morning Joe questioned whether
the blemishes were magic marker blood or
something that may have exacerbated by
Trump slamming his hands on the table
during his defamation trial surrounding
statements he made about writer E Carol
what I love about this is that uh first
uh we here at timcast when I saw the
story you know the first thing I did was
I scrolled past it I saw I saw a story
and says what is wrong with Trump's
hands i h and then I kept going and then
I read an oped from the Covington
Catholic kid Nick Sam I'm like oh here's
an oped I'll read about that story that
matters to me and uh but this is picked
up by all the cable allet and so finally
when I started realizing everybody's
talking about this I Google searched
blisters on hand and golf blisters is
like one of the first things I found and
I was like oh Trump goes golfing he goes
golfing all the time uhhuh it could be
this other thing that we like better
because it assassinates character also
you know it's no it's like you mentioned
the EEG e Carol trial that's going on
and of course they would come up with
syphilis because it links it to
something you know sexually untoward and
then it almost like meta verifies her
stupid narrative Democratic strategist
James Carell didn't mince words they
don't look like cuts to me I think
there's a good chance this man has the
clap okay uh that that's ganaria and I
do not believe that causes blisters on
your hands but I don't know for sure he
he said Wednesday on the politicon
podcast noting he consulted a number of
doctors who all came to the consensus
that Trump has secondary syphilis though
he didn't identify the doctors and added
the disclaimer that the photos may have
been doctored holy crap okay so civilis
has phases and secondary I I could be
totally wrong but I think secondary
civilist is like a a year or two out or
something that yeah it's a while later I
the only thing I really know about
syphilis is that n had syphilis and
didn't I think it killed him cuz they
used to drink Mercury how do they get
away with writing stuff like this and
calling conservative conspiracy theorist
is beyond me that's such a good question
well they're a cult you know I mean like
so you have post liberals former
Democrats disaffected liberals
conservatives all of us disagree on
policy but the one thing we agree on is
these people are crackpot cultist
weirdos and so they'll call all of us
conspiracy theorists when we say stuff
like yeah you guys are you guys are
crazy mhm but that that's it and and you
ask how do they get away with it well
how do they get away with a woman
claiming that 30 years ago Trump raped
her in the Bergdorf or whatever and
Trump and Trump's like there's no
evidence I've never met the woman I have
no idea what she's talking about and
they're just like hey you're liable
anyway
so whatever it's crazy Who's Gonna Want
To Live I'm sorry just I would not want
to live in any of these places these
cities we're we're we're really getting
New York is beyond the communist utop
communist dystopia nonsense where quite
literally a a stranger you've never met
I think Trump they're they're saying
that he knew een Carol whatever and
there's like a photo of them at a party
at the same time and Trump's like I I've
been to a bunch of parties with a bunch
of people I don't know who this person
is he went to every party of the
socialite set and he was probably the
most well-known person in most of those
and multiple women came to take pictures
with him right it something yeah so one
day you're going to get sued by someone
you've never heard of claiming that you
I don't like in this instance for Trump
raped her or whatever sexually assaulted
her this woman just
clearly everybody everybody agrees is a
whack job yeah it's a whack job but this
is this is the the current state of
American politics and it's funny because
I'm like guys I'm going to say it civil
war if there's not going to be one if
there's not going to be one and maybe
not it's just social collapse and so
maybe it won't ever be like Mass scale
fighting over control of the government
or anything like that it'll just be
you know somebody who lives in Iowa
doesn't View Missouri as their neighbor
anymore I feel like part of the time
timing of the story has to do with the
fact that they were at melania's mom's
funeral today it's like there can't be
any moment where the trumps seem like a
sympathetic family they're just going
through something actually we have to be
reminded that we we being mainstream
media hate him at all times at all costs
uh and I find that to be really ugly I
think people become disenchanted with
consuming news that's basically fueled
on speculation and hate if you actually
look at any of the uh the websites that
can show you the views of these websites
that of other websites like a ref or Sim
rush it shows that their views have went
down significant it's a significant drop
in CNN and all the mainstream because a
lot of the viewers were stressing if you
look in the comments CNN them even
removed the comment section off their
websites because of this it's like why
are they still talking about Trump they
said you don't even have to Bass Biden
we just want to know what our active
president is doing they were more
concerned about Trump I remember when he
was just taking the high road and being
very quiet they were criticizing him for
golfing saying that he was no longer uh
car about the audience like bro I
thought he wasn't president anymore so
this is the nature of the media Donald
Trump is forced into an emergency bunker
by far-left insurrectionists and the
media made fun of him and called him
bunker boy I'm like so when the far-left
interfered in the official proceedings
of the United States by firebombing the
White House that's not an Insurrection
but when J Sixers interfere in the
Electoral count that's an Insurrection
I'm like either they're both
insurrections or or neither are
insurrections neither pulling a fire
alarm as well oh yeah dude firearm how
that guy is not just locked up well and
he has great ideas for reparations now
too that he was talking about today like
he got a new promotion yeah I I I think
you know what I was just saying about
social breakdown there's a big story
right now where uh Texas has begun
arresting illegal immigrants I love this
story in defiance of uh arting him today
oh yeah yeah yeah and uh I'm telling
like yeah we we grain of sand being
added to the Heap at some point the
federal government either has to admit
it's been defeated look I'll put it this
way by Texas which is kind of perfect
well that's it the dam has broken it it
the dam is broken okay we we are not
necessarily looking at Fort Sumter
although I wasn't the one who made this
point I can't remember they made this
point um I think it it might have been
like Benny Johnson I'm not sure that uh
yeah I think it was Benny he was saying
that the federal you know start of the
first Civil War first Civil War the
federal government is saying this is our
territory the south is saying no it's
not and there's a standoff nobody really
dies but we call that the start right
now in Texas the Federal government is
saying uh uh Texas is breaking the law
is breaking federal law barring them
from access to the river and they have
no authority to enforce border issues
and Texas is saying we're going to do it
anyway the dam is broken because now
there's one of two scenarios the first
scenario is the federal government loses
has no Authority no control and the
confidence in the federal government's
ability to enforce the border is gone
Arizona makes it the next move which
they should be doing I mean with ktie
Hobs they won't but if the federal
government loses here and they are not
able to enforce with Force the States
win and that diminishes the power of the
federal government substantially to
where other states will start taking
similar action how do we know this is
going to happen because when California
started defying federal law with their
Sanctuary cities and Sanctuary States we
then saw the emergence of gun
sanctuaries where several jurisdictions
started saying we will no longer enforce
these federal gun laws so a Texas for
instance has completely ased the uh ban
on suppressors and they say uh uh in and
and fact check me before you got and buy
suppressors but my understanding is if
you're in Texas you can buy a Texas
suppressor and they don't adhere to
federal law so it's the it's the ATF who
have to come and stop you from doing it
the other path is the federal government
decides the only way to assert their
Authority and prevent the breakdown of
confidence is to by force stop the Texas
National guarden Law Enforcement from
prohibiting them that would mean an
escalation of force from federal law
enforcement against Texas
National Guard or police well what's
interesting too though is the Border
agents that Biden deploys what they
typically do is uh they're not there on
the on the line dealing with the Border
they're mostly just processing people
that's all they're doing so the National
Guard went in and said you know we're
going to actually close the border here
and the law that Texas passed was
interesting because it said that it's
illegal to enter ta enter Texas uh
Crossing an international border
illegally so they made being they made
made illegally crossing the border
illegal again illegal again well let me
pull this up this is CNN Texas
authorities have begun arresting
migrants at a public park near the US
Mexico border official says Texas
authorities arrested migrants at Shelby
Park in Eagle Pass Texas late Wednesday
evening in charged them with criminal
trespassing marking the first arrests of
migrants since the state took control of
the area at the US Mexico border last
week and official said the arrests were
announced by Lieutenant Chris Al oliv
alerz how you pronoun alerz at the Texas
Department of Public uh of Public Safety
on social media where he also posted
videos on acts we get it we get it
single adult migrant men and women were
taken into State custody while migrant
families and children were transferred
to US border patrol I'm hearing that the
Texas planes and buses that were
shipping migrants to to various cities
have either stopped or slowed around the
same time the state has begun arresting
the illegal immigrants okay my friends
social breakdown the federal government
declares the border the international
borders are their Authority and I
believe that is the case but they are
also obligated under article 4 section 4
of The Constitution to defend States
from Invasion the federal government is
facilitating Invasion not doing their
Duty so Texas says we no longer adhere
to what you are claiming Texas is now
solely enforcing the law on their border
passing a law saying that they have the
authority and jurisdiction on this
international border the federal
government sues them saying no you don't
Texas deploys armed National Guardsmen
to Bar federal agents from the border
from the river and we have the makings
of the grain grains of sand are being
added to the to the Heap of secession
wow so does this escalate to the point
where Texas eventually declares
independence it may all of these small
moments when you know it I always use
this analogy how many grain of grains of
sand make a heap MH what we are watching
right now is Texas asserting its own
authority over an international border
Texas deploying armed soldiers to Bar
federal agents from what the federal
agents claim is their
jurisdiction if the federal government
backs down and gives up this just
shatters confidence in the federal
government if they want to so what does
it mean for other states next you get
New Mexico Arizona other states being
like well the federal government has no
Authority anymore they've given up and
they'll start asserting their own
authority or the federal government
shows up in force with guns and says
stand down and if that happens we have
to ask Will Texas stand down or will
Texas say F you know right and where
does that
lead that's really fascinating I feel
like we're Americans it seems like
America as a whole is going back to I
don't want to make it seem like it's
radical but kind of it roots and its
culture of just keeping the government
accountable and if you won't take care
of this nation we will cuz that's kind
of how the founder fathers were I feel
like just Americans as a whole they're
going to start making founder fathers
proud and that's not saying to start a
revolution or anything or
even stand on your rights yeah they're
standing on the rights and they're
telling the government they've taken too
much power give it back to the stat
abits criticism of immigration for for a
long time now that there are laws in the
books that the federal government could
choose to enforce and they don't in fact
they have let this become a a
increasingly burdensome problem for the
states to deal with and then telling
States they can't do anything to stop it
and so I think in some ways this rise of
you know a state Governor that is
willing to do something is uh
inspirational I think it's more likely
that border states would fall suit and I
actually wonder if it's going to be the
the States along the northern border
they're going to do something something
right they're seeing a wave of
immigration as well I mean at a certain
point it's a danger people yeah there's
the can well people will fly to Canada
and cross to the northern wow the other
the other thing too is a lot of what's
going on in terms of um family
separation and just releasing migrant
kids and releasing the people who travel
with migrant kids creating essentially a
golden ticket for adults who bring kids
AC across the border it it's not a law
it was it's a judge it's a Flores
settlement that went through in 1987 and
then has been consistently challenged
and back and forth where I think it
was 20 it was under the Obama
Administration uh there was this judge G
in um or maybe it's g in California who
said that since because of the Flores
settlement says that you have to release
immigrant children illegal immigrant
children without any do without any real
delay that meant that you also have to
release the adults that came with them
so it created this golden ticket
situation where the um border patrol the
DHS is required to release children
under this agreement and if they're
releasing children they have to release
the adults too and that's actually how
the family separation thing happened
because under Obama it was like okay you
have to release ille illegal immigrant
children so let's separate them so that
we can release the children and detain
the the adults that came with them and
then that was that was changed so I
don't know why everyone's holding to
this um ruling by a radical judge why is
that what's being upheld it's pretty
weird I think we're about to start
seeing a lot of positive Domino effects
from the last about 12 years we've seen
a negativity of domino effects and
nothing I don't care what someone does
with a sexuality but there has been a
downward spiral in America after Obama
legalized homosexual marriage at first I
do distinctly remember the lgbtq
community simply only asking for the
right to be married married after that
they started ask for representation in
television and it went from television
to kid TV shows and went from kid TV
shows to going to preschools and Etc so
it's a domino effect of just legalizing
the marriage itself or even it wasn't
Obama it was the Supreme Court yeah but
uh it was in the Obama yeah it was
oberfell the decision yeah I look the
domino effect the slippery slope these
things are are are real they happen and
so everything we're seeing now with
Texas on the
border I want to make I want to make
sure it's clear I'm not actually
predicting anything I I'm saying if x
then Y and what I said several months
ago is if Texas is arguing that the
federal government has abandoned them
sooner or later they're going to send
law enforcement to go and do this
themselves well then they did it's not
so much that I'm saying like I have a
vision I see this there's multiple
things that could happen here federal
government go in a lawsuit Texas backs
down we have no idea but we can say
these things all move in One Direction
so we're going to see Texas now they're
making arrests sooner or later we're
going to see the federal government
retaliate in some way you have no
authority to detain these people could
it escalate to the most extreme what if
Federal the federal authorities go to
local uh jails and bring guns and say
transfer these people into our custody
Texas says no you're going to release
them into our state and the federal
government says we don't care what you
think release them now into our custody
a lot these things could happen but they
don't have any jurisdiction over state
prisons they only have jurisic Federal
AR the argument is that the state has no
uh jurisdiction over illegal immigration
so the federal government would be
saying you have illegally
detained people that are under our
jurisdiction could you really see
Biden's DHS being like we're going to
get the guns all they know is law fair
that's what they do
consistently I don't know perhaps it's
very very simple and the answer is no
the federal government backs down if
that's the case other states are going
to say then the federal government is
impotent and incapable of how many they
back down truthfully how many times can
I remember like can we remember in
recorded history the federal government
backing down yeah our government backing
down I remember like Ruby
Ridge you know I I remember the federal
government refusing to back down to such
a degree they kill a bunch of kids in a
at Waco yeah and Waco as well yeah so I
don't I suppose the issue here is that
we're dealing with state law enforcement
versus Federal but again
1860 right 1861 more precisely that
ideally and hopefully Donald Trump gets
elected he then goes to Texas and says
our forces at your are at your disposal
and then there's no longer animosity and
there's no longer a clash but right now
the Biden Administration is facilitating
an invasion and facilitating illegal
immigration and human smuggling Texas is
trying to do its best to stop the
criminal activity of the Biden
Administration but only in so far as it
affects their state sooner or lat we
have to reconcile with this country that
the Biden Administration is a criminal
Enterprise facilitating human smuggling
and they've been doing it for years they
have been it's like 10 million people
they're flying children on planes they
are smuggling to such an extreme degree
they're trafficking children yeah from
Venezuela and all
over yeah it's interesting too because
you have the Democrats freaking out when
Trump says that there's going to be a
mass deportation event and there's going
to people are going to be held before
they're deported and then you have Eric
Adams the mayor of New York saying you
know what we're going to do because
there's all this crime around the the
illegal immigrant shelters we're going
to put in curfews at these shelters and
it's like so you're making a detention
camp for migrants where they can't leave
right that's what you're doing so Eric
Adams is going to do it and one thing
that's interesting too is we see that
happening a lot with Democrat Mayors
where they are forced to use the same
tactics that everyone's did crying
what's his name Johnson in Chicago as
well I wonder how extensive their uh
just their motives of getting to the
country is I know that
also dig to go from underground and come
back up I just wonder how organized they
have it now just the illegal IM
organized because all they have to do is
show up and they're let in well yeah you
have that like who needs a tunnel
they're just going to open the door you
see border patrol like putting T um
ladders up to like help people climb
over there's a video of border patrol
opening the gate and letting them in
onto private property too because
they'll say it's it's too dangerous like
we have to help them because otherwise
they might fall and hurt themselves you
Texas National Guards that arresting the
CBP
guys it'd be interesting I would ra I I
mean I think it's more likely that um
the federal agents I would like to see
them defect to the state level I would
like to see them leave their jobs I mean
obviously they work in an industry you
know you know if if your expertise is
working on the border just go to the
agency that's actually enforcing the law
and that's I do not understand how there
are men and women in law enforcement in
the state of Texas who are actually on
the ground dealing with this every day
and they have not reached the point
where they're just like we got to start
arresting these fed these feds they they
are human traffickers I don't care if
they're wearing a badge they are human
traffickers and they are armed it's time
to start arresting them for facilitating
human trafficking it is human
trafficking directly and the cartels
advertise on Tik Tok and Facebook and
what yeah and there was just a story
that we were looking at the other day
Taylor Hansen did it where it turns out
that Charities contracted cops in San
Antonio to like facilitate
human traffing watch Taylor Hansen's
reporting on tenet media we have the
culture War uh show tomorrow morning on
tenant media but Taylor Hansen has
uncovered a lot uh police officers using
public equipment to facilitate human
trafficking I mean dude it is it is
insane I I I I I just don't understand I
really don't we are watching abject evil
this is not like a cop took a bribe
these are police officers in their
vehicles using public equipment to
protect and facilitate human smuggling
operations this is not me being cute I
human trafficking okay strong language
human smuggling definitive Le 100% there
there was a story I pulled up from the
doj from several years ago where two
guys in the military go to Went to went
to prison for transporting illegal
aliens we now have the entirety of the
Biden Administration the facilitating
the whole DHS and I'm just okay I get it
perhaps Texas brief their guys said guys
we got to do this one very very
carefully to avoid dramatic escalation
but here's the move we're going to make
if I was in Texas Sheriff's Department
or National Guard or whatever I just be
I just walk up to a CBP guy and be like
put your hands on your back I'm you're I
don't care I'm just you know what man
people people always make excuses for
cops always make excuses they say oh you
know cops can't choose what law to
enforce okay if that was the case all of
these guys would be in jail in Texas the
moment a CBP up look let me let me ask
you you guys something if uh you're
you're in a a cartel gang mhm and you're
seen driving around a cartel vehicle and
you're armed do you think the cop's
going to go well he's not doing anything
so I'm going to leave him alone or do
you think they're going to be like
that's a cartel vehicle and that guy's
got a gun we're going to pull him over
and and and investigate this is cartel
activity yeah uh if if you were part of
like let's say Al-Qaeda okay a big Isis
truck with an Isis flag is driving
through Texas and a bunch of guys with
with guns are M mounted on the back do
you think the cops are going to be like
I can't really enforce it against
they're at the very least going to
investigate and say probable cause is is
a terrorist organization that gives us
the probable cause right to stop them
turns out you have right to keeping bar
arms you have right to free speech we
got something interesting going on here
but terrorist organizations are a line
if local law enforcement at state level
knows that all of the
CBP and federal law enforce have been
facilitating cartel activity and human
smuggling for what for what reason do
they decide I'm not going to even stop
and question these guys yeah it is
because they're like well he's wearing a
badge yeah if a clown walked up to you
wearing a badge I'd say screw off at a
certain point we need the law to be
enforced they're doing it I can respect
it but I don't see why they're giving a
free pass to the criminals in the B
Administration who've been facilitating
this I agree that's why I think that
it's so bizarre that you won't even have
the uh republicans in Congress bring up
the potential impeachment against my
orcus MTG keeps saying like let's
impeach Alejandro my orcus he's
destroying ouraring right now yeah
they're holding hearings but they
haven't they haven't gone for it and I
don't know why they could have had him
out of office you know 10 months ago
they could have had people introduced a
year ago yeah it's happened multiple I
think it's happened at least I can think
of maybe four times they can't get a
vote vote on it I don't know why I mean
it just seems like the most obvious
thing I also don't understand why in a
show of good faith the Biden
Administration wouldn't be like okay
mayor you got to step down because we
have angered everyone like they could
rotate they want it but they could fake
you out with like oh well we listen to
you we're trying to compromise because
their thing always is is Republicans
aren't willing to compromise repu we
just heard this from uh JB pritzer the
other day he was like he sent that he
put that um complaint to Abbott in the
news he begged Greg Abbott to stop
sending ilg like stop sending because
you're being you're you don't respect
humanity and I can't believe you would
do this and it's cold here so agree to a
bipartisan solution right like they are
always saying Republicans are the ones
who aren't willing to compromise when
for Republicans this is a hard issue you
have to close the border you have to
close the border and it's interesting
you had um Chuck Schumer saying that
there would be no border deal without
money for Ukraine it's like that that
makes absolutely no sense it's crazy
well friends there is a solution before
us in this story from the
post-millennial Teen Vogue says Biden
and Democrats are losing gen Z support
claims they may not vote at all I'm sure
all the Republicans would absolutely
accept either they don't vote or they
vote for Trump then we have this from
vox.com what uh what Democrats panic
over young voters misses okay sure
whatever the point is even Vox is
acknowled is is acknowledging Democrats
are starting to freak out because more
and more polls are coming out that
somehow a 77-year-old republican white
man has garnered majority support among
the youth vote believe it it it it has
been throughout my life the youth vote
is always a bunch of naive young
Democrats that's how we got Obama yeah
Obama's like vote for me I'm going to
not blow kids up and then I was like
okay sounds good to me and like and then
as soon as he got in he like like blow
them up too many of them I can believe
it it's super believable because I just
see a lot of the young kids their whole
like their whole culture is like based
like I see a lot of them just the most
average kid they like being based and
being based is kind of like being what
conservatives would consider like you
know un not well not unhinged but they
really don't give a f about what they
say yeah it's the most offthe things
that's considered bass liberals would
not approve of and majority of you like
bass culture there's this video of a
young woman where she's like looking in
the mirror holding up her phone and she
she's talking about how like oh you got
offended because I said something well
that's to effing bad I love that you
shared that yeah it's like it went viral
young kids are seeing that kind of
content mocking the woke going viral yes
they want to get followers I watched one
video where right some of it's super
cringe I'm sorry guys I get it you're
young you're trying to find
and it's like this one dude every single
video is him sitting in his car
screaming I like that guy and sounds
like yeah he's just like why is it that
all of my and I'm like okay like I get
it it's like he's he's people are trying
to do you mean the guy that sounds like
Gilbert godfried it might be I don't
know but it's like a younger guy they're
all trying to find their stick and so he
does this thing where he's like why is
everything so
expensive what's yeah what's happening
and he's like I'm not a Republican or a
Democrat and I'm like you're a
republican the moment you say I am not a
Republican or a Democrat you're a
republican that's those are the rules I
didn't make them up unless you're Oliver
Anthony and then you're just irrelevant
all of a sudden yeah that was
interesting right he's just he I me talk
about one hit wonder well the thing he
actually had handful of really great
songs yeah I mean they were not bad
songs I think the issue with him and
he's probably still enjoying a lot of
success look just because you know the
one song was the biggest song in the
world at the time he's he's he found a
stable base of support and you just
don't see him because you're not a
country music folk fan and he had like a
baby stuff too right like he might not
be but I I will say this he was really
just a regular guy who did not
understand that when he came out saying
like I'm not you know political he was
telling all of the people who promoted
him back off MH yeah so congratulations
we all backed off for sure also
Democrats are always like I am
Progressive I am a feminist like they
they want you to know what their labels
are whereas it's activists for their
whole every aspect of their Liv and they
wear it as their whole identity right
whereas like you think for yourself you
might lean sort of conservative you
might think of yourself as a Libertarian
like if you have to look at me and say
like oh well I'm not either one then
you're already not in the pool of people
who probably hate you well and the thing
too with the with um oh you were going
to say something D I'm sorry I was just
going to say I think these polls kind of
also exemplify the amount of propaganda
that Democrats push out because in the
summer of 2023 I don't know if you
remember one of the main things they
were pushing in their campaigns was Joe
Biden had a lot of the Gen Z behind him
he was hiring a lot of Democrat uh
influencers as well like Harry Sison and
other young ones Chris maray and like
this black guy I saw it's like eight
young influencers came out of nowhere in
the summer all of them had the same
message almost copy and paste say Jen Z
loves Joe Biden Jen Z loves Joe Biden
they would do it about two times every
about every three days and they just
started to vanish off you can see that
their audience has just withered away so
I can definitely see they were pushing
that propaganda super hard because they
probably had these numbers before the
general public right like cist is just
gone I haven't seen that guy and it's
just so much it's just propaganda and it
was they were huge when they came out
and it seems like okay maybe Biden do
have geny and it just shows I mean I
think these polls just a few months
after the summer should just show people
to give it some time over anything that
Democrats say you think Biden was
basically trying to convince he was
trying to convince them cuz they I think
they had those numbers I think with the
resources that bid has he was tipped off
that hey it ain't looking good turn the
and that's why they brought Harry and
all the other propaganda and it still
didn't work he was getting ratio
non-stop it was it was sad you know and
some of it has to do with Gaza thing
Trump is one of the most Punk Rock
presidents we've had in a really long
time and what I mean by that is clearly
he is not punk rock in the pure sense of
what punk rock is what I mean is the
fact that he's willing to insult people
on TV make fun of people for being fat
he's punk rock in the sense of screw you
you know you know what's really funny
based B right exactly go back to 1990
Donald Trump is the embodiment of f you
I won't do what you tell me and rage
rage on behalf of the machine has become
the F you you better do it we tell you
so I I kind of imagine if you're a young
person and you had all these people
telling you to be woke or else and then
Donald Trump is laughing and just
pointing at the fat kid making fun of
him you're like that's fun yeah silly
irreverent I can do what I want to do
leave me alone Democrat somehow has
created their own problem it said just
do censorship and the forcing of all of
the ideologies it just isn't natural
these kids they got common sense I'm and
they hate it like their teachers push
this stuff when you have
teachers Pride ribbons on everybody and
teachers saying like let's all discuss
our pronouns you can't joke about it
like
imagine fastest way to make it unol kids
don't think that with their teachers
want to do is cool you know like my son
came home with some stupid assignment
about how you have to the assignment was
to do a biography of a scientist that
was not white or male what he was like
he was like white male that's who we're
doing and I was like what the hell is
this and he was like I don't know Mom
this is so stupid like New York or West
Virginia West Virginia
Tim I've been saying Cassandra's been
warning about this this is why it's so
important what we're trying to do with
West Virginia in Martinsburg because
these woke leftists are it's a cult and
they they move in lie about their views
get elected to positions and then start
injecting this stuff into the schools
that's right there was another thing
that happened a little bit before winter
break where a group came in to talk
about suicide prevention and started
handing out the number for the Trevor
Project the Trevor Project which is like
we're going to trans your kids yay you
know that's their whole Jam because
that's who they think is is committing
suicide when actually it's young white
males who are committing suicide right
the group that the TR project probably
wants to isolate or alter you know
fundamentally I think that's the
craziest thing we we can acknowledge
that suicide is a huge problem but when
you look at the numbers they don't want
to talk about who's actually committing
suicide and that's and it is yeah it is
and it is mostly like young men and it's
it's terrifying because you know we need
our young men yeah I find extremely
concerning that the Democratic audience
don't really talk about the suicide
rates of transgenders when they are the
main people that enable them I mean you
would think they would care about all
aspects of their health well this this
is one of the most important things that
I think needs to be talked about in the
uh in the whole issue of the the gender
ideology stuff the first thing I'll say
is with the news being Shan Strickland
that what the woke left has done pink
news for instance they said that Sean
Strickland said being trans is an
infection he quite literally didn't he
said the weak man who is an ally is an
infection he didn't say anything about
trans people he was actually talking
about the journalist but the issue I see
is the first what I I saying earlier is
I got no issue with trans people I have
an issue with people who are pushing
people towards dangerous medical
practices well or pseudo medical
practices which can result in a loss of
life so uh for instance when we had
Lance from the surf Sun I said that I
believe is a trans genocide and it's the
left that is pushing it and I stand by
that they're trying to sterilize or the
the things they're offering up to trans
people to a great degree sterilize them
and that will prevent them from having
children genocide doesn't just mean you
go and you kill a bunch of people uh one
component of genocide would be to
sterilize them Mass sterilization and
Eugenics and so what's happening now is
you have a young person who's suffering
gender dysphoria and they immediately
jump to let's give them irreversible
drugs and surgery which will prevent
them from having families in the future
it seems like some ISS like for whatever
reason they want to do this maybe it's
because they're misguided maybe it's
because they're evil but as you referen
suicide the point I made was if the
suicide rate of uh trans individual
suffering suffering from uh gender
dysphoria is around 48% I believe right
is that the number 40 to 50% but the
desistence rate at best for Trans
children is
65% some it could be as high as like 95%
or whatever that would mean that
Democrats are increasing the probability
of suicide in children because if you
leave the child alone there's a two to
one chance they desist and they're and
and they and they they they uh puberty
cures them of their dysphoria MH they
then push them to transition giving them
a 50/50 chance of dying which means the
greater chance of survival is leave them
alone this is according to the studies
that are available right now from the
from the major acemic institutions why
then are they pushing it I think they're
evil and they make money off of it right
it's it's more effective to have someone
who's suffering and dependent on the
medical system I think ultimately it's
uh they victims right and if if like
we're talking about teenagers being
defiant so if you're a teenager who goes
through surgery who goes through
whatever your body's permanently
disfigured some might come out and say
like no this is wrong but a lot of them
will just suffer but then also feel
threatened and say like no no no you
guys don't understand I just have to
keep trying I have to keep pushing it
becomes this thing and they are trying
to build people who will eventually
support this movement because they know
that to admit that they were wrong is
ultimately to say that they have made
the worst decision someone could make
and Adit you wrong I mean I mean the
opposite it's the opposite of submission
is not even admitting it so that is a
submissive type of person that they're
building regardless because if they
can't stand for themselves they're
submitting it is a it is a low it is a
low um suicide rate even in the trans
Community a study this is from leor a in
the City Journal which I've referenced
uh a bunch of times from last spring a
UK study found that the suicide rate
among Clinic referred transgender
identified youth was
0.03% or four deaths out of 15,000
gender distressed minors in the US where
between 2.1% and 99.1% of Youth now
identify as trans and where rates of
diagnoses of gender dysphoria have
skyrocketed we are told the numbers of
trans kids have always existed all right
in which case why hav seen a suicide now
what's the what's the suicide rate for
Trans adults uh I don't know you want
pull pull that one up because uh either
we're dealing with false statistics the
argument being that suicide rates are
really high and that's we're trying to
prevent that's what Jack dorsy said to
me on the Jun podcast or the issue is
that kids who are suffering from gender
dysphoria have an extremely low suicide
rate and the argument for them to
receive this uh uh surgery or or uh
medication is based on false false
premise it says uh this is the Williams
Institute I'm not super familiar with
this it's out of UCLA it says 44
reported suicidal ideation 7% suicide
attempt and 21% nonsuicidal
self-injury over their lifetime well
what's the percentage what's the suicide
percentage uh 42% have attempted it 56%
have engaged in nonu we'll clarify then
attempted suicides at 42% for Trans
adults meaning these kids don't if that
data is correct these kids are not
trying to do this right but if they
become adult that that that actually is
the point I'm making you are increasing
the likelihood they will attempt suicide
by putting him through these
transitions yeah also it doesn't really
the leor superier makes another argument
about um the way that the data is
collected as being also a problem I
would believe that well we should uh
we'll jump to this story we have a tweet
from the man himself Shan Strickland who
has been lighting up the internet as
he's preparing for his fight at UFC 297
this Saturday super excited everybody
should be watching this fight it's going
to be amazing I'm it's going to be a lot
of fun I'm very excited he said hate
speech isn't real I didn't know I was
fighting in North Korea and he posted
this video Shawn is for the people oh
man you got to hear this but when have
you ever seen a UFC champion George St
Pier anybody else stick up for you
guys I do it I do it I
am not chasing the Chinese check mark of
n
I don't give up about that I care about
you guys I care about you guys being
free I care about you guys having
freedom of speech I give a about
you guys and I'll tell you what you guys
are awesome and I cannot wait me
this man to go to war for you
guys let's go no they're cheering he's
wearing a shirt it's got the Canadian
maple leaf says Strickland and says make
Canada great again again this guy's a
warrior man this is uh I see a lot of
people posting after his previous
comments this is how you push back on
the machine he's the big ask he is the
pendulum swing and uh it's epic so I say
we should be supporting him and uh that
does bring up an interesting issue of uh
Bud Light Bud Light is about to is is on
the on the verge of collapse did you
guys know this yeah the strike you heard
you heard about the strike coming up no
there's a strike too yes yeah and uh
someone even super chatted saying that
uh earlier in the show they said they
they they work at a budlight bottling
plant and the strike is absolutely going
to happen some reports are saying there
will be no beer on the Shelves come
March you look budik doesn't want to
anheiser they don't want to give people
raises they don't want to give them the
guarantees they're asking for they've
abandoned the negotiations I wonder why
it is they're backing away from uh uh uh
the negotiations could it be that
they're down 30% in sales I think it
really shows that conservative have
buying power real true buying power at a
level that we haven't seen seen in a
long time maybe it's not so much the
issue is conservative anymore it's that
regular people stopped buying the
product I think that's a big part of it
I think there are people who are active
in politics and and took part in the
boycott because they they believe in it
and they got caught in the mov but I
think there were a lot of people who
just said like this is going too far and
I don't like it anymore just the most B
well the most standard American right
the standard American and I think that's
almost more impressive because they're
harder to reach I mean this is what any
kind of political strategist will tell
you trying to get someone who's not that
engaged who's moderate to go out to the
polls is is impossible but they're all
voting with their dollar this way and
it's not necessarily for party it's
against ideology and I find that really
kind of inspirational going into the
next
year yeah it's it's gonna be wild if
there's no Bud Light come March like the
the strike happens and dude you combine
the boycott you right now with with what
everything Sean Strickland is saying Bud
light's in the hot hot seat because
you've got you know pink news running
these these articles saying that he
called trans people an infection which
he didn't but he said I'll tell you
about budlight budl light's going to
have to say something that but I think
the woke left are going to try
everything in their power to avoid this
fight but more importantly you combine
the drop in sales with the workers being
upset they're not making enough money
not getting the guarantees they want
they stop making the beer what happens
if they stop making the beer nobody's
buying the beer what happens if no one
no one buys the beer you stop making the
beer yeah so wow then the strike would
be the final nail in the coffin could
you imagine if Bud Light just went belly
up that would be crazy
and it would be all from Dylan milany I
me will old historic American company I
mean that's really fascinating well
isn't it owned by isn't it owned by
anheiser it's anheiser Bush right
anheiser bush is like it's all based in
St Louis yeah if but it's I think Bud
goes as a brand goes completely under I
I'll make this broad I'll make this
broad if budlight as a brand I don't
think Anis or bush but budlight goes
belly up and they're just out like like
the budlight brand is done mhm or in a
much broader sense if budlight drops off
as a major a major brand such though
that it appears more like an ancillary
brand no one really pays attention to
I'm being very broad with this to mean
like if budlight is wiped out of the top
market share I will write a check for
$110,000 to the charity of Matt Walsh's
choice for telling me I was wrong on my
Bud Light boycot position so if so cuz
look the strike that's happening now I
believe is a product of the boycott
people aren't getting paid enough
they're getting angry they're not
getting paid enough budlike can't pay
them more ditches the negotiating table
and and they're probably saying we can't
pay people more sales are down 30% and
the employees are like then we're going
to go on strike there's a possibility
they just go you know what bud light's
dead and if that
happens okay I will I will write I will
write a check to a charity of Matt
Walsh's Choice shout out Matt Walsh he's
like no boy C still on my point was we
should declare Victory and put pressure
on budlight to adhere to our worldview
and our framing of the things I still
think that's true like with Sean
Strickland coming out saying these
things my point is to clap and cheer for
budlight saying thank you budlight for
sponsoring UFC and and Sean Strickland's
message to force them to publicly speak
either in favor or against it once again
creating a ripple effect in the boycot
now that being said if all we had to do
was sit back and just completely ignore
them and that would result in the
Cascade effect of a strike and then a
collapse I will admit I'm wrong and I
will uh make a donation to a charity of
Matt Walsh's Choice what about if it
goes Belly Up what would other companies
do would they be afraid to insert woke
you know marketing into oh yeah maybe
we'd get some of those old 80s beer
commercials back where to it was yeah
they're like on the river there's a boat
everyone's wearing shorts secr I don't
know if you guys saw about in November
Victoria Secret made a huge announcement
they were going back traditional yeah
right no one wanted to buy lingerie
after seeing it on a bunch of mod did
you did you hear about who would have
imagined that did you hear about the uh
the smokeless Snoop thing I tweeted
about this the Snoop Dog campaign to
smell the smell sell the fire pits
failed and apparently the CEO got
removed or whatever let me just explain
something to you guys the idea that you
would hire Snoop Dog to sell outdoor
equipment is the stupidest thing I have
ever heard it was horrible horrible it
was horrible because of the engagement
it took over the internet in terms of
sales and engagement it just felt and I
think the main problem is they Mass
promoted a product that cost a lot of
money I mean that product is like it's
it's it's not just that it's like Snoop
his fans do not buy camping equipment no
no hold on hold on I'm sure he's got a
lot of fans who buy camping equipment
but no they do not you want like bare
grills to be announcing this because
everybody watches like I want one of
those it's not like target market yeah
it's not like the big um they had those
lighters that had the like extended uh
flame and it was uh Snoop Dogg and
Martha Stewart that that was like their
they did this like commercial pairing
and he was selling them and she's like
you can light candles and he's like or
something
else it was perfect he collaborated with
her it was still a collaboration they
like had a show they were like hanging
out for a minute so I I bring this up
because Victoria Secret is like we're
going to sell lingerie using big fat
models and ugly women and then all of a
sudden nobody wanted to buy their
products anymore yeah and it's because
women and men want to look at attractive
models and think I can be like that if I
buy this product that's why you buy
that's why you buy stuff you buy stuff
because you're like oh I want I mean
they already did that the advertising
companies already told us when you buy
our product you have access to this
lifestyle and no one wants access to the
lifestyle of being unable to get off
your couch cuz your butt's too big but
but it's not that like Victoria Secret
in particular right you've got all these
big fat models and ugly women and the
average woman who Megan rapo too right
so yes so first the woman who is buying
Victoria Secret I imagine I could be
wrong but I imagine as thinking I want
to be attractive to my my husband to my
significant other here is this beautiful
woman she looks at that and says wow I
could look like her if I buy that
lingerie or whatever and then she buys
it the man sees that woman and goes yeah
my wife could look like that I'm going
to buy it then you put a big fat woman
on the on the on the wall and the
regular one looks at that and says I
want to look like that actually go ahead
I was going to say they it's beyond L
they'll use you know all kinds of models
whatever and I'm not always against this
but the thing is if you're looking at an
ad and something doesn't look good on
someone whether it be lingerie or a
shirt or a skirt I'm not going to buy it
because it doesn't look good it's like
selling it's like selling Viagra and
having the models being depressed you
know Viagra they're always super happy
like extremely excited they're having a
bad time you're like no thank you
there's a thing too where when you're
buying clothes online you can check and
see and it will show you a model who's
wearing any of the sizes right and the
further you go up you're like oh if I
have to buy that size I'm not buying
this cuz that looks terrible you know no
for sure I mean it almost Works to the
consumer's favor being like maybe I
should just skip buying save my money
good in my closet right now man I'll be
really excited if Bud Light goes on
strike and they just don't make any they
just tank yeah because look I I talked
about Fusion quite a bit I mentioned
this even like last week oh I think I
mentioned the other other day hey I had
a friend worked at Fusion which is the
ABC News Univision joint venture all
operating on investment yeah this is
like last night and they were announcing
negotiations to unionize and I told my
friend you'll get fired in two seconds
because your company does not make money
the moment you walk up to the president
and say all 300 employees want a 10%
raise he's going to say You're Fired I'm
shutting the company down cuz you don't
make money these people at budlight who
are like we're going to go on strike the
boss is going you guys are not selling
any product okay we are down 30% we're
not giving you more money and if they
say then we won't make any beer then
they're like okay well then we're done
that's the
end I don't I can't imagine they would
want to abandon budlight as a as a brand
because it's such a like a longstanding
iconic product but at this point I kind
of think it's entirely possible with the
upcoming strike the perfect storm hits
and they just say it's going to cost us
$20 million to try and recover the lost
product from the strike the brand is
already down 30% it's being mocked
relentlessly we're not getting our
customers back just stop the bleed stop
throwing good money at bad it's imagine
being that marketing manager who pulled
the Dylan malany stent and then got
fired she's never going to get a job
again oh they're going to she's going to
be in marketing like college courses
yeah yeah the great failure the great
failure because she clearly didn't have
an understanding of the brand at all
there's that Quiznos commercial that no
one ever forgot of the weird chinchilla
things screeching and they they you
never you might be a little too young
and I was like Amish I was not allowed
to watch TV growing I'll pull it up
Quiznos I wasn't actually Hest for
clarification I just had strict parents
I bet all I have to do is search for
Quiznos commercial sponge monkeys here
look look at this this thing right here
love what yes that's my subc
conscious
no this is incredible they are crunchy
they are War because they
them they got a PE okay well this was
make advertising great again I mean this
is just great wild was a massively
successful advertising campaign and they
teach about it in marketing courses as
to why it worked why it was so good why
everyone loved it and I think you know
who they really hit with this midnight
Stoners hungry and they're like man and
they're just staring at it like what but
the real isue children children saw this
and were like hilarious let's go it's a
lot it's a lot it's that they no one
would forget it you watch it and you're
like what the did I just watch they used
to do this thing back in the day where
in magazines there's like a famous
example of of what they would do with
with ads is a a woman like a teenage
girl in a swing and she has three legs
one two legs are going forward and
there's a third leg going backwards
creepy they would do a ton of things
like this so that when you were flipping
through
it would catch your attention oh like Do
Double Take and look at it longer yep
and so this is exactly that so you know
with Bud Light maybe maybe they were
like remember the Quiznos creepy sponge
monkey things you're giving them way too
much credit no no hold on hear me out
someone that lady she publicly she goes
we want diversity in Bud Light Behind
the Scenes she's like remember that
creepy weird thing Quiznos did let's
hire Dylan mainy oh man we chinchilla
may maybe they were think that creating
some kind of shock content would
generate massive buzz and attention to
create I I I bet they were thinking
controversy good I feel like they just
took their their core audience for or
their core consumers for granted they
said we can do whatever and they'll buy
it no matter what so we might as well
just push to get a really Progressive
audience in here didn't that start
initially like in February uh did Moy
thing is reaching yeah if it did that
really should show the people that it
only takes about 12 months no matter how
powerful the brand is if them really
like getting their pockets hit it takes
a real toll the M mulany was already
very distasteful to a lot of people at
the time he ended up with uh I think it
was around febrary like uh mulany ended
up at the White House talking to Joe
Biden about how important it is to make
sex changes for kids worst ER why are
you talking about this like you want the
guy who's pushing for kids to have sex
changes to push your to like boost your
beer that doesn't make any sense it
super weird and I think even people who
a lot of beer drinkers want grandkids
you know they don't a lot of them do
it's one of their main concerns I open a
beer and they're like but when am I have
a grand that's what I do so uh let's
jump to this story from the post
millennial which is currently loading
here we go resurfaced footage shows
United CEO performing Lady Gaga drag
routine at company Halloween party okay
for a variety of reasons uh I am going
to hereby announce where possible
timcast will no longer use United for
any of TR I mean it so we book uh I
think we have 1.5 flights per day for
this show uh and so why the reason it's
1.5 is that guest flies in same day
guest flies out yeah so that actually it
it I think we might be be doing two per
day two two flights per day not 1.5 two
per day and one or two on the weekends
and then pop culture crisis has a guest
on the weekends we don't book flights
for every single guest mhm some people
come from DC it's one of the reasons we
chose to be in the area because a lot of
uh higher profile political commentators
are are local some people who live in
like Philly can drive down it's only a
couple hours so there's a wide range of
areas that we're in but typically we're
flying people out every day and uh I
have already instructed the staff I said
is it possible for us to completely
ditch United Airlines and we believe it
is I want to be careful on how I
describe this because when you're
dealing with something as big as an
airline when there's actually very few
it may not be possible in some
circumstances to say we won't use United
that's why I say we're possible however
I'm pretty sure American Airlines uh
operates in in in all the exact same
areas that being said the challenge with
any kind of boycott is that you know
American Airlines Delta and all these
brands are doing the exact same garbage
the issue here is that the CEO himself
has advocated for illegal activities
that's right ill committing crimes the
CEO of United has advocated for hiring
on the basis of race which is a
violation of the 1964 Civil Rights Act
that's illegal and so long as this
company has a guy doing a drag Lady Gaga
routine where he celebrates breaking the
law and being racist we are not going to
utilize their Airline now I know I know
in 10 seconds someone's going to point
at American Airlines and they're say
look at all these bad things they're
doing and to which I say okay Spirit
Airlines it is uh you know but I I don't
know our guest are like we don't want to
go anymore we'll pay for our own travel
it's funny I was looking at the United
thing I said this morning I even tweeted
I said I don't really feel that safe no
more being on their planes after seeing
that it's a rough kind of wacky it is
isn't it I mean like I'm very nervous
all female like black flight crew it's
like man that that just don't look right
man it's it's not right I want a man at
the front of it honestly I don't care
want the doors I want the doors to stay
on the plane crazy it'll sound racist
and it'll sound kind of coonish but
honestly I'm safer feeling if it there's
a white man flying my plane only because
every time I've flown it's been a white
pilot I like what I'm used to is what
I'm used to the issue here is these
diversity higher
practices make people they exacerbate
racism yeah because if you say we are
going to hire lower on the on the ladder
to be diverse the Assumption then is the
pilot you have who's not white must be
not as skilled and that's that's not
fair could you imagine being like the
best pilot in the world and you're black
but then everyone's like yeah he's
probably not that good I'll be like come
on man
like I worked my ass off for this and
then these far- leftists come in and
start making the claim that everyone's
got a higher lower down on the on the on
the talent pool they're making the
problem worse yeah there was a Gallup
poll that said 52% of black Americans
oppose affirmative action and they're
they like the affirmative action ban
that the Supreme Court I I hate
Democrats man yeah Democrats talk to
black people the Yale study you remember
this one yes they talk down to people
they talk down to black people but but
talk talk down is that like the right
way to phrase it they dumb down their
language and act stupid when they're
talking to black people yeah they've
conditioned us to think that way and
speak that way they they've made out our
language that that dumb down slang type
language that simpler type terms the
non-political verbiage really like when
they were pushing ebonics yeah look at
this this is from 2018 white liberals
dumb themselves down when they speak to
black people and new study contends I
despise these people so much dud I mean
think that's definitely true just having
been in Lefty circles for my entire life
that I think that's definitely true I
had a friend tell me that she preferred
the racism of the South to the racism of
the North she was like at least in the
South you know that they're racist they
say that they're racist then they treat
you normally in the north they say
they're not racist and then they're
racist at you okay but then the
Scientific American ran this article
this year saying uh black children who
speak African-American English are
routinely misdiagnosed with speech
disorders so they're saying like
everyone's Mis diagnosed with disorders
sure of course but also there's this
level of like this institution which
because we know educators are
predominantly left leaning they're
saying you're supposed to act this way
culturally but also we're misdiagnosing
you I mean this is like the most
conflicting information to give
especially young children the way you
speak is okay sometimes but also in
school except maybe we think it's wrong
and they complain about code switching
yeah it's crazy it's all mixed
messages yeah thought that was a crazy
headline when I went to Sweden I said it
was one of the most racist places I've
ever been to oh wow and everyone was
shocked but they're all so Lefty and
they're like Progressive and I'm like
uhhuh yeah and they they put all their
migrants into enclaves where they
separate them brag about how not racist
they are and then don't hire them I'm
like it's it's it is this air of I'm
such a better person I'm not racist and
then when it actually comes down to
practice they're like oh no get away
from me yeah that's what we see with
white liberals in the United States even
but uh going back to you know United
here's here's the video we'll uh we'll
play it for you I know you guys don't
want to watch it but you're going to
have
to so uh
okay so would you respect someone who
like if this was your boss and this is
what you looking at now this was a
Halloween part this was like a Halloween
thing but it was still a company
Halloween things okay I got to be honest
I I really don't care that the dude is
doing Lady Gaga drag stuff I it's it's
like whatever man I guess uh I think
Lady Gaga makes great pop music more
power to her if this guy you know gets
his rocks off by dressing like a woman
and dancing around in front of his
employees hey I'm libertarian just keep
the kids out of it the issue is that
he's on in an interview with axio
bragging about how he intends to break
the law he's sitting there being like
I'm a criminal and a racist at the same
time and I want to cause harm to this
I'm like dude screw you this is just
like okay I I said this I I personally
boycotted United long before we knew the
CEO was some weirdo you know what I mean
some some racist well cuz United is not
good I have flight credits with them and
once I'm using them up and then we're
done I just don't fly don't fly United
man I'll tell you we were flying back
from I think it was uh I can't remember
where we were we were in California I
think it was when when I went to Tiana
for the uh medical stuff and then on the
way back over the weekend we stopped in
Vegas that's what happened when we were
flying back from Vegas United at in the
morning switched my plane ticket to a
different plane without telling me so
when I showed it to the airport my
ticket wasn't working I had to get a
different ticket and then they put me
from first class a ticket I bought and
they put me into the back into the um
basic economy seats it's crazy and they
still charge you for first class as far
as I know I never got I I I did I I
attempted a charge back saying I did not
buy these tickets I want a refund I want
my money back I don't know what happened
with it to be I think we got I think I
got a refund I'm not sure I'm not sure
but I think I did but I'm sitting here
thinking like how is it that I paid all
this money and now all of a sudden the
charger stole my credit card I'm on a
totally different plane to a different
city in a different seat I didn't pick
and my flight was still flying out on on
schedule the issue was that the flight
so it was uh like Houston to DC and the
flight I was supposed to be on in
Houston was delayed so they took it upon
themselves to move me to without without
telling me and I'm like I could have
just gone to Houston and then opted for
a a flight there right just because my
flight was delayed do not I was I was I
was livid it's insane that they would do
that they put me on a flight from Vegas
to Denver to DC that's annoying and they
do it because they're probably thinking
we don't want people sitting in the
airport if we can get them to their
destination just do it don't ask them
screw screw United do not fly United if
you do you're supporting you know
racists you don't be racist do you right
do you hir
why are you asking me wow no I'm just
kidding but the thing is I can't take
this person seriously like I get it he
can do whatever it's not that I don't
want him to not do whatever brings him
Joy it's just like this is your boss and
like I get it's a comedy halling party
but like it's about choices like I don't
know like that's just if he chooses to
represent himself that way how does he
represent his airline when you're Bo
when you're bowing Max
7379 is crashing the last thing that's
going to go through your head is going
to be this
video that's horrifying I hate that yeah
that is horrifying I fly a lot for work
I travel a lot and uh I've been
increasingly
um wary of air travel yeah and I'm kind
of like I have can I just drive across
the country what if we just do that do
you remember Co when people road trip
all all kinds of places yeah but I was
flying during Co cu the airport ports
were empty the only people you ever saw
in the airports were wearing Maga hats
and you'd be like hey what's going on oh
wow it was cool there was nobody on the
flight and it was a bunch of conserves
and Trump supporters flying around the
country being like it's cheap Mark
Cuban's debating people online about
like diversity and stuff but the there
there's there's one point that Mark
cubin cannot ever refute publicly
stating your intention to hire someone
based on race is a criminal act MH or
it's like it's it's admission of guilt
in and the intention to commit a crime
we have a law in this country that's
been there for 60 years that you cannot
discriminate on the basis of race and
Mark cu's like no that's a good thing
okay well look it's really simple if you
got an issue with what Mark cubin is
saying sue him it's about time everybody
who's sick of the diversity quota stuff
starts suing the moment any company okay
so first you need standing so if there's
a company that says we're only let's say
you guys listen you're listening okay
tell your friends this you work for a
company right they say we got a new
position or we're promoting but it's for
people of color file a lawsuit you will
win in two seconds you'll put 10 grand
in your pocket it is illegal what they
are doing you cannot do this there
there's uh uh you see this all the time
with like housing it was a big deal
because on Craigslist there are a bunch
of women who say like no men allowed and
you cannot discriminate in housing and
it caus a lot of problems there are guys
who sue bars the bars will have ladies
night and they'll say 20 20% off all all
drinks for women and so there's like
this old guy old gu like there's an
older guy who's in his late 50s who just
goes around the country suing These Bars
he instantly wins you know why cuz the
bar gets served to the lawsuit and they
say what is this we're being sued for
having ladies night and their lawyer
says yeah that's illegal you should pay
them and they'll be like he wants 10
grand they'll be like you should pay him
because you're going to lose and it's
going to cost you more than that and
they write him a check and then they
cancel ladies night if that's been going
on for 20 years all I can think of is
John litz anybody who works for United
right now should be following a lawsuit
calling a lawyer and saying the CEO on
axio said they have quotas for people of
color I feel like I am being held back
and not be given a raise because of my
raise blah blah blah the company has
explicitly stated the CEO they commit
they they illegally
illegally discriminate in in the
workplace sue them women are people of
color so they just classify both of them
into like either or yeah just kind of
dis Civil Rights Act is written it's
yeah but that's and then now it's retro
yeah it is and now it's retroactively
gender identity is part of it yeah oh
man so everywhere it says protections
for women it's protections for gender
identity
that makes me mad did you see the thing
where like now um You can pick
non-gender or opposite gender on your
passport on your that's going to
workport really well for you when you
fly to other countries and they arrest
you that's right and that's what they
said that's what the state department
said they were like some countries won't
honor this passport if you lie on it and
you can also lie on your child's uh
birth certificate now you can put on
exgender I'm for it I'm for it look I
got to tell you man you're like just go
as far as you can make yourselves insane
like looking as insane as you can
creating a false document when you go to
the US the purpose of a passport is to
identify you to a foreign country they
will then choose to Grant you excess
some countries have what's called Visa
upon entry a lot of them do some of them
have they don't have visa on Entry but
they basically do like I think when I
went to Egypt that you show up you walk
up to a there's a counter and then they
give you a Visa you pay the money they
stamp your passport then you go to
immigration control and that's not visa
on Entry because you had to go to a
kiosk a lot of countries you walk right
in you walk up you say I got an American
passport they say stamp thank you for
your money some countries don't do this
and scroll they they they go through
your passport identify you and you have
to have pre-approval before entering
this country if you lie on your passport
and then apply for a Visa and then show
up and the and the person at the border
you know Customs or whatever for this
country says you app applied for a Visa
claiming to be a man but you're a woman
or you're a woman claiming to be a woman
but you're a man denied you are a liar
you're in serious trouble you here's the
other thing too it's going to get really
really interesting because when you're
trying to fly internationally to a
country that requires a Visa the
airlines will say please you know uh
check check in to prove you have the
Visa because if say United flew you to
Brazil and you did not have a Visa guess
who's responsible for bringing you there
now what happens if you go to United and
you know you're very clearly a man but
your passport says woman and you have a
Visa and the Visa says the same thing
because you apply online you uh to get
like a Visa you go through a broker and
they send in the photos and then Brazil
will approve then you show up and they
go uh you lied you are not a woman
you're a man why are you trying to sneak
into the country it's going to be funny
when United approves you you land and
then they say United why did you allow
this person to lie on their visa come to
this country you're responsible and then
unit's like oops it's going to be crazy
because look there's a lot of countries
that are not going to tolerate this so
you got all these right now there's not
that many people who do it like what was
it the small the low thousands of
individuals who've actually changed
their passports but this is why I tell
people like some people even joke about
it like oh I'm going to get an x on my
it's funny I'm like nah you shouldn't do
that it's really dumb yeah because then
one day you're going to be like hanging
out and I don't know you're going to
you're going to go on vacation to like
Romania or something someone's going to
look at your ID and they're going to be
like this is fake you're under
arrest yeah plus I feel like we should
like like the gender thing before it
goes away we should be like yes put my
gender on my passport because one day
it'll be vintage and they will just
remove it entirely like it also though
speaks to what we were talking about
earlier with regard to trusting federal
government how do you trust a government
that allows fabricated Federal documents
like that's just crazy like oh you the
the the United States government puts
out identification documents that are
rif with lies and they approve that why
would you it makes you question anything
else they put out right any official
docum any official study anything they
fund which already we're in trouble
which is like kind of how we operate
anyways yeah dude this stuff's so weird
it's just so it's so it's social
breakdown right before our eyes no one
is asking your gender because they're
trying to insult you or your sex
nobody's saying like tell me what's in
your underwear that's the Argent they
make what do you want I I think it's
really funny because um they always try
to pull this thing where they're like to
wants genital inspections for for
sporting events and I was like it's
called the physical everyone gets one y
like I don't know why you're calling it
a genital exp inspection but you get a
physical you go to the doctor to make
sure you're okay what are you talking
about every Olympic athlete ever is like
Yes sounds good this is completely
normal procedure it's funny because the
left's argument is if we say males can't
compete in female sports it would
require General inspections and I'm like
dude they take their blood they like
extract the blood from these athletes
which is much more invasive also it it
it's a lie anyway because you don't need
a genital inspection to tell the
difference between a boy and a girl or a
man and a woman it's blatantly obvious
just by looking at them even from across
the room you can tell you can tell the
difference that's all made up between
men and women I don't know what you're
talking about it's all pretend obv it's
just obvious it just depends on how you
feel like that I was listening to some
uh NPR uh interview when I was coming
today and they were talking about like
oh yeah I mean gender is is not real and
masculinity and
they were saying masculinity and
feminity are made up Concepts but how
can that be possible if we see the
patterns repeated over and over again I
think this is the weird thing that all
of these conversations are trying to do
which is that your brain desires to
categorize and process information as
fast as it possibly can right and so the
idea that we have identified a
difference between males and females
that's both physical but also
psychological it presents self and
behaviors like this is supern normal it
helps us Advance as a society why would
you want to be like actually it all
doesn't matter actually it all means
nothing actually if you assume any of
this stuff you're bigoted and hateful
and you should question yourself like
why would you want there to be chaos
unless you in some way thrive in the
chaos or profit off it yeah or it
furthers your own um rewriting of
reality and your own sense of discontent
within yourself right like you need
other people to be miserable because you
yourself are
miserable misery loves company should be
like the motto for TR I think that is
one of the weird things that happens
though people who see people who are
like thriving and doing well want
the left entirely the left entirely is
misery loves company yeah yeah it's it's
it's terrifying what a horrible way to
live you know like that when when Biden
I've talked about this a couple times
but when Biden did his first speech he
was saying you know we're the party of
the future and they're the party that
wants to divide and hates you anyways
I'm going to spend this whole time
fearmongering and telling you how this
like Maga extremist group is trying to
ruin the government and also I'm only
going to talk about I believe the
shielding is what created a misery they
were shielded from everything Shield it
from criticism Shield it from bullying
all the stuff well because of cowards
yeah it's because of cowards uh you know
I I think of it like a fire right you've
got a small fire in the in the kitchen
and when this first started you needed
only a few people who knew how and were
willing to put the fire out and deal
with it instead everyone stood around
and was just like it's not my kitchen
I'm not doing anything and so they
watched as the fire grew and grew and
grew and it got to the point until
finally it caught the attention of
people who tried to put it out and now
we're winning we're pushing back on it
if just when when all this wokeness
started the the the the people who were
working for these companies just said
shut your mouth we would never have
gotten to this point yeah and at the
time I remember because you know like I
spoke out against trans stuff in theater
in New York and that didn't go super
well oh wow um yeah it was didn't go
super well um but no one else was
willing to speak out even my friends who
all agreed with me right but they
wouldn't speak out and you could see all
over the place people would say quietly
they're making me put my pronouns in my
bio for work I don't agree with it but
they would do it anyway and there was so
much cancel culture that people would
say you know I'm afraid to speak out and
be like oh it's too bad that you're
afraid to speak out and it's like at the
time I remember saying to people like if
we just all said the truth if we all
just spoke up we couldn't get canell
because there's way more of us than
there are of them we know what reality
is we know what the truth is and all we
have to do is stand up stand on the word
speak up say the truth and everyone was
afraid to do it we were all just pushed
around by like the green-haired Mean
Girls with nose piercings who were
screaming at us telling us we were
bigest this silent majority phenomenon
has been going on for a long time I mean
this is also true of saying that you
should you know restrict B immigration
over the border for a long time
Republicans were afraid to talk about
this Democrats at one point were the
ones called calling for Border
restrictions and ultimately became this
you're being racist you're being
anti-human Arian people need this you
can't talk about this and then culture
shifted and it suddenly became something
that you could talk about I I find this
well it's because people kept talking
like a bunch of us just kept talking
even though we lost our jobs or friends
or whatever and I think it's just like
nothing new Under the Sun kind of one of
those things cuz Council culture I feel
like any priority that Embraces Council
culture they only have about 8 years
maximum to have that dominance because I
remember in the past distinctively when
I was younger my mom was a republican
Christian and she was also a part of
Christian Council culture I remember it
being a thing like counseling Harry
Potter counceling GTA counceling NWA
that was Christian Counseling these
things and left was Tipper Gore too TI
Gore hated all that and they copied what
Christians really did and magnified it
you know it intensified it to the point
that we see now but since it's
intensified I say conservatives had they
grasp on America through Council culture
maybe like 12 years since it's so much
stronger I think the lipo's only have
about six Max yeah
Supreme dominance people could only take
so much just like maybe with
conservatives they could only take so
much with liberals they took it way too
far too fast and we just don't have that
uh the patience for it just right it's a
lot if you hit as hard as you hit you'll
leave just as fast was that frustrating
for you growing up if your mom was one
being like you can't do these things did
you see the it wasn't really that she
was just joining the boycotts I remember
like with Harry Potter I could never
watch Harry Potter or if she ever seen a
Harry Potter book my mom would burned a
book cuz she said burn she hard to burn
a book
it's she would find a way she would find
a way she would put did she tell you
like I'm doing this because I believe
this or were you just like my mom's wild
Christian conservative belief she'll say
that's witchcraft that's a devil uh
don't fund token and I think it's kind
of funny cuz that's one of the main
person people speaking out against
transgenderism now which is crazy so it
really just shows that things come full
circle conservatives were canceling her
in the past now Liberals are canceling
her right over two different two totally
different things I think sometimes
there's this especially if something's
been popular culture uh people feel like
oh well I don't want my kid to like
resent me for keeping this from them and
so they they're hesitant to say like
this is why we don't do this as a family
or like they're trying to find a way to
sort of balance I and I can understand
that it must be really difficult I don't
have kids I can't imagine that challenge
maybe Li can talk about it but that that
idea that your mom was like it's not
even that you can't read it it's how
we're going to burn it it's kind of
fascinating it's yeah they it was a lot
of Christians or at least conservatives
around my area would not engage in any
of those things they didn't call it
Council culture at the time it was
called standing on your beliefs or
standing for Christ but un a political s
it is Council culture in my opinion
counseling GTA a video game and now was
looked absurd but back then it was very
serious business yeah with my son like
he can read any book on the Shelf just
ask me about it let's talk about it he
can watch most things I mean there's
restrictions on his you know there's
restrictions on his laptop and stuff but
like I'll sit and watch YouTube content
with him and then I know what he's
watching and I know what he's interested
in we talk about it yeah yeah it's also
funny you mentioned earlier about the
fact that the kids are now voting we
talked about ear story kids are not
voting towards gen or in general voting
towards the the right conservatively
it's cuz like the like you said the
liberal the liberalism thing has been
cool for so long and that's like the
mainstream now and pun would be like not
would not be doing that and that's
what's coming around you can't be based
in be mainstream because Bas is
literally uh a revolution against the
mainstream whatever was M right yeah I
remember when I finished when I was in
high school I had this was years ago
this was in the 90s but I had like you
know dyed blue hair and I was of like
Punk rockish or whatever and when I went
to college everybody was punk rock and
everybody was like wearing fishnet
stockings as tops instead and like all
this stuff and I was like okay I'm not
going to do that anymore and my hair was
suddenly normal and I started dressing
preppy and I was like okay I'm wearing a
button down in jeans now y'all that's
the but I think that non-conformity is
it's it's what I find really interesting
about the way like teenagers brains
develop is that they're looking for
social acceptance but also really want
to create and carve out their own
identity and watching teenagers navigate
this in such a uh intense political time
when what's at stake is is a lot I mean
if you stumble down one Rabbit Hole
trying to search for who you are it
could you could have lifelong
consequences right now uh but that
desire to not do what everyone is doing
is still there well and your teachers
aren't cool so when your teachers are
pushing you know counterculture on you
you're like that's not cool MH no you
look awful that's I want to talk to you
guys about this uh new cartoon coming
out in a couple hours actually it's
called has been hotel and I'm seeing
some uh outrage over it because it is as
some describe well the veneration of
demons so you have this uh this story uh
actually I I'll play I'll play the
trailer for you guys the first thing I
want to say is I'm not acting like
this's this big outrage campaign against
it there's just I see people posting
these things uh on on Twitter talking
about how it makes Lucifer to be the
good guy it eliminates the concept of
God it is a fictional show about demons
in hell that are being killed by Heaven
because Heaven's actually the bad guys
who want social order and in hell
they're trying to convince bad people to
repent so they can get let back into
heaven I don't see it as inherently like
good or bad but there is a question
around producing content that is popular
winning a culture war and uh Biblical
teaching so let me just play this for
you and then I'll get your guys thoughts
on it once upon a time there was a
glowing City protected by Golden Gates
known as Heaven it was ruled by beings
of pure light angels that worshiped good
and shielded all from Evil Lucifer was
one of these angels He was a dreamer
with Fantastical ideas for all of
creation but he was seen as a
troublemaker by the Elders of Heaven for
they felt his way of thinking was
dangerous to the order of their world so
he watched as the Angels began to expand
the universe in their ways from the dust
of Earth they created Adam and Lilith
equals as the first of mankind but
despite this Adam demanded control and
Lilith refused to submit to his will she
fled the garden drawn in by her Fierce
Independence Lucifer found her and the
two rebellious dreamers fell deeply in
loveing wished to share the magic of
Free Will with Humanity offering the
fruit of knowledge to Adam's new bride
Eve who gladly accepted but this gift
came with a curse for with this single
act of Disobedience evil finally found
its way into Earth with it a new Realm
of Darkness and sin and the order Heaven
had worked to maintain was shattered as
punishment for their Reckless act Heaven
cast Lucifer and his love into the dark
pit he had created never allowing him to
see the good that came from Humanity
only the cruel and the wicked ashamed
Lucifer lost his will to dream but
Lilith thrived and empowering demonkind
with her voice and her songs and as the
numbers of your mom when we need so did
its power threatened by this Heaven made
a truly heartless decision that every
year they would send down an army an
extermination to ensure hell and its
Sinners could never rise against
them but Lilith's hope remained and her
dream was passed down to their precious
daughter the princess of of
hell don't worry Mom I'll make you proud
so there's this uh it's it's a show on
YouTube there's another show that's
related to it super popular it's got uh
they get like tens of millions of views
but basically the what I'm seeing from a
lot of people they're commenting saying
that that the the propagandists I don't
think it's I don't like that look Prime
all they're saying like Amazon Prime is
doing this Amazon Prime has sound of
freedom on it and it's actively
promoting sound of Freedom I'll take it
it also is now launching this show I
think they saw a big audience they said
let's take it but the controversy arises
in that this show makes it out that one
that Lilith is real uh and you know a
lot of people again I'm not a Biblical
scholar but people are like that's
blasphemy and that Lucifer is not a bad
guy but also people are saying it's not
even actual actually biblical there is
no God Heaven is evil Heaven wants to
just go and exterminate all these people
by sending soldiers down to kill them
and uh my my whole take on this is I
think it's interesting because if you're
concerned is that major media is funding
massively shows that corrupt Biblical
teaching in some way whether
intentionally or otherwise the answer is
to build culture and counter it by
making your own content shows cartoons
or otherwise complain about it's not
going to solve anything but I'm curious
what you guys think if if if it even
matters it's got amazing production
value I will say that like it it looks
well drawn why were you wincing okay the
thing is it is it is sort of interesting
to think of this as like a thought
experiment where someone was like I'm
going to tell you the story and then you
have to spin it so it's completely the
opposite of it like in that way it is
almost fascinating what they have done
yeah I mean I don't think it's that bad
of a thing to be honest with you I mean
I'm not a Satanist but it's just vice
versa it's just it's entertainment yeah
it's like what if God was evil art from
the from the bad guy perspective there's
video games that let us see from the bad
guy perspective yeah I don't like the
idea of like restricting art I think
that you have to have like
countercultural ideas and this would be
countercultural CU like my Christian
beliefs of course but like the other
thing that like when I'm looking at it
I'm like did you did you who wrote this
like did you grow up in a church and
learn the story and then you were like
but I have decided to change it or are
you someone who doesn't understand like
this story of Adam and Eve and
everything and you have been like well
Adam actually seems like a really
oppressive guy and he wouldn't let eat
from the apple and that's very rude well
you saw like in the beginning it's like
Lilith would not submit to ad to the man
she was fiercely independent she's such
a feminist girl boss then she falls in
love this silly trickster Satan who's
just hanging not Satan or whatever his
name is you know like like it's it is
like I'm wincing cuz it's my brain being
like this is very weird but on the other
hand like whoever wrote this should go
work for some top government PR spin
room because they really can be
like SP fny about it someone commented
that it's low-key based because it has
all the gay people in hell and I was
like that's actually should be rather
offensive to them but the issue is
because the people behind it are I my
understanding is they're like woke they
created a bunch of characters that you
know are like them and so all the people
that are in hell are leftists which I'm
sure that comes from like them being
like Oh everyone else says I'm going to
hell because of whatever however I live
my life or whatever no I think it's more
like the characters we make need to be
diverse so let's make all of our
characters diverse and it's like you
just put a bunch of woke leftists in
Hell well isn't that isn't that where
they out of they'd probably be happier
there you know that's what they're
saying they're like Heaven's a bad place
the term diversity has changed too cuz
now diversity pretty much means insert
different type of like lgbtq in the past
it used to be like bring an Indian here
bring an Asian right here bring a black
right here it's completely different now
what people Asians Asians are no longer
considered diverse according to most
government contracts that require quotas
what for real yeah are you serious yeah
yeah Asians east east Asians as well as
South Asians I know in New York in the
um architecture and engineering
contracts they have quota systems for
minorities but quota system there's no
quot for Asians because they are over
represented in those fields it doesn't
count anymore it was the Asian student
groups that brought initially brought
the admissions law Supreme Court this is
why I no longer identify as Asian I'm
actually Hispanic because I think that's
SM Hispanic means speak Spanish I'm
Native American and so because me and
Elizabeth Warren same amount but but so
so no no check this out when you are
filling out a form and it says Caucasian
Hispanic African-American whatever
Hispanic means speak Spanish yeah it
does not mean you are from Latin America
or whatever it could mean that M but it
literally means Spanish speaking that's
why they say there's white hispanic too
bad I so I'm just gonna be like I speak
Spanish uh it uh how do I say El somero
D esta la bibla I was uh dog sitting for
Dane our our our marketing guy when he
went on his honeymoon and he and his
wife have two dogs and they both speak
Spanish at home and so they came to my
house and like one is calm and one is
really scared and my roommate and I were
trying to figure out like how to like
talk to them we're like it's okay you
know different and then it occurred to
us that like these dogs only speak
Spanish and we were saying like I can't
say anything I said like bibla but she
said like you're you're Bonita and one
of the dogs like turned around and
looked at her like yes I am like they
had no idea what we're talking about
until we started speaking Spanish I
speak Spanish
AA so Candace said that means outside I
guess she she didn't know about the
melee meme but uh it means out like it
could it's a verb too like get out and
uh it's always weird when I hear people
tell tell me this because I went to
Spain during the the uh uh the M
something protest M24 whatever protests
and the cops this I I love this in uh
France no wait wait we'll start with
America in America the SWAT police uh
the the the right cops they all hold
their trunion they stand in line and
they go like this as they move forward
and they yell move move in uh France and
in Canada you know what they say what
Bou ooh yeah right move right but you
are bougie you are out here pring in
Spain you know what they say
AA they yell AA as they're pushing
people out like get out get out and so
when I was in Spain hearing them yell
that I was like I kind of understand
what they're saying they're saying like
get out move go away or whatever and
then my friends were saying they're
saying out out out and uh then I had
people tell me that it means outside and
I guess it's like for people who only
just speak a little bit of Spanish like
that means out outside why are you
saying that and I'm like Javier mle was
yelling aera as he was ripping the
things down and you know Dane messaged
me and he was like it means like get out
or outside as well D fact Tex Spanish
all the time so I speak Spanish now that
means I'm Hispanic and I am no longer I
I tweeted identify as Asian because uh
there were these leftists arguing that I
don't qualify as mixed race unless I
assert that I identify as such that the
actual DNA within my body and the race
of my mother is meaningless and the only
thing that matters is I choose to
identify as such and I'm like really
because identity is a political
designation it's notty isn't isn't
anything about your me you identify as
Asian I'm totally Asian what are you
kidding me Tim you're out of your mind
well I'm Hispanic from now on because it
means speak Spanish take that Dane
I as oh is that what it takes
interesting I'll get back to you guys
with my you should be Hispanic should be
with my bibla Dan's going to be like
absolutely not I'm actually an
indigenous American yeah you are that
makes sense to me I mean I I
legitimately am first generation
American I'm the child of immigrants
people just don't think it's that spicy
of countries you know can you say do
tacos de poo por I honestly I'm afraid
to on the internet because it's going to
be so bad but if you say it you can then
claim to be Hispanic because
no no one ever said in order to speak a
language you have to be smart right like
you don't have to be good at it to speak
exactly like I was at this I was at this
Mexican wedding in Puerto varda several
years ago and I my Spanish is terrible
but I did know how to continue asking
for mango Margaritas that's the most
important skill of all time it was very
important and as the night continued I
thought I got more and more emboldened
in my Spanish sure I wonder why who
could what could have Fu that what could
have fueled that um but yeah by the end
I was pretty I was pretty secure in my
espanol it was really good my accent was
exactly like this one too so it was
going over really well I mean I I do
think that is what people will end up
doing I think they already do it to just
sort of claim whatever tangential thing
they can because it all sort of becomes
meaningless at least to me like it it
seems to like it all falls apart and
it's too bad because there are people
who really do feel like their their
cultural ties even though they were
raised in America very strongly and they
observe different Traditions or whatever
else but for the most part it's like
what boxes can I check so that I get
more advantages with the federal
government or with universities I never
got to say what I thought of that thing
and I I just think it's the
glamorization of evil mhm and that's
really I think that's not a great thing
but I wouldn't prevent people from doing
it I do think that there needs to be a
lot more art being made by people who
are not leftists it doesn't have to have
activism in it but it should be artistic
make cool stuff do you guys know what
burrito means no I do know the origin of
burritos however what is the origin of
burrito well you're probably going to be
like no no be that's totally wrong but
uh Mexican Cowboys would go out and be
Cowboys and they would take burritos and
they would put them um under does come
from the word the word for donkey like
aito means little donkey and it would it
would stay warm all day just like tucked
in well uh I was told that they're
called burritos is because when the baby
donkey is born they wrap the blanket I'm
learning so much about so they called
the a burrito it means a little donkey
my favorite thing at at Taco Bell is a
gordita cuz means little fat girl I will
never look at these the same again this
crazy eating lots of little fat girl
gordita yeah it means little fat girl
we're all now Hispanic but mostly CU we
go we can read the Taco Bell menu that's
the important part that and the
Margaritas yeah like I okay I'm probably
wrong Gordo means fat I would be like yo
Margarita po Gordo means fat and theno
and ITA means like child small so goura
is little fat girl man that's that's
hilarious what an amazing language I
think that they all come with faces on
them for now on like a little I guess
you have to say gortex now if you want
to be politically correct go to go to
Taco Bell can I get a chal
lupix Hispanic people don't use the X
they like reg like what is this no they
hate it they hate it we should totally
do that we should film a video where we
go to Taco Bell and order the gordic yes
any us to go to Taco Bell you know I'm
in fits for work Tim there's a there's a
I would say right now but there's a
blizzard coming we're tacos we got we're
in a state of emergency right now
actually that's true that is crazy West
Virginia is in a state of emergency
because because uh we're getting a lot
of snow we don't we don't have plows I
mean we're mountain people I think
that's I shouldn't say we cuz I'm an
immigrant to the
Mountainland an even more recent
immigrant to the mountain I'm a refuge
West Virginia but I do feel like now
that I live in a Southern state I can
say y'all and I that's the I'm into that
but I do want to say to all of our
Mountain folk we did migrate here
legally to this great Mountain Land of
West Virginia but uh legal Asylum here
right when it snows though so when we
were coming back from um from Iowa we we
landed the plane landed on four inches
of snow and was sliding it was crazy and
then outside the airport there's no
plows so there's 4 Ines of snow pure
pristine untouched snow everywhere and
so the cars we're driving through it we
had to drive 20 20 to 30 mes hour all
the way back because you're going up
hills and down Hills It's relatively
mountainous and uh by the time we got
back to the house we couldn't make it up
the driveway our driveway is not like a
small driveway it's like 10 ft it's it's
like it's like vertical it's like it's
like a thousand feet and so we got 10
feet up and and then slid back down and
I was like let's start walking so when
it snows and it's going to snow tonight
the state is like you will slide down
the mountain so you've been warned I
actually called my dad and asked him how
to drive on ice because I only got my
driving license a couple of years ago so
I never and I grew up in New England but
I I would have learned I mean by rights
I should have learned how to drive yeah
and then in New York there was no uh I
mean they everything right away we're
going to go to super chats so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show right now with
all your friends because it's the best
show everyone agrees at least that's
what I've been told and head over to
it's huge head over to
timcast.net paid working for this
company is all entirely based off of the
Tim pool Daily Show that means for
everybody who watches and supports Tim
cast IR on the clips we use that money
for investing in projects we use it for
uh creating new cultural stuff we're
using it for traveling to do shows say
like in Iowa and things like this and uh
yeah when you become a member you are
just helping us uh expand culture and
and work on the mission so it is greatly
appreciate it it makes it all possible
here we go that's Dan zask first or no
first you are in fact the first you win
a high five from your
roommate I hope they are keeping score
somewhere yeah ready to rumble says
congrats Dom you are the sixth most
Community noted person you lie like
almost no other you should be banned for
lying so much yeah I got I'm getting
targeted it's crazy I even proved it
there's this one user that's actually
Community noted 86% of my
content they're only talking to
conservatives yeah I posted it on my ex
they're only talking to conservatives
yeah this what they do um when I called
out Ronda santis the Des santis campaign
stole uh one of our videos and then uh
put a tag on it saying paid for by the
disantis campaign oh yeah that was
messed up and then when I when I tweeted
like hey they did not pay for this the
dantis people put a fake Community note
to trick people what they were trying to
make it so so here's here's here's the
context there was a short video that was
about 7 Seconds long the clip was filmed
by elad eliahu a reporter uh formerly of
timcast news now of
scnr the disis campaign took just that
clip and nothing else sent it out in a
tweet with a tag saying paid for by dis
santis in the
video when I said hey they did not pay
for this we did not get any money cuz
I'm like I'm not saying take it down I'm
just saying we had nothing to do with
the disis campaign they put a fake
Community note to make it seem like it
was a 3 minute long ad and that the
message was part of standard reporting
processes four political ads to which
I'm like I got a fake Community note to
trick people and I was like no no no no
guys I am not saying that they that that
that's not the correct uh thing I'm
saying if you take only our reporters
footage then claim paid for by D santis
that sends a very different message to
if you made a commercial where a guy is
talking and says did you know that LGBT
activists want your children watch this
video paid for by Ronda santz that I get
not what they did a raw version of our
clip with their tag on it and then when
I said we have nothing to do with this
they put a fake Community note these
people are are are dirty man it's dirty
yeah they'll do whatever they can but um
it only happens when you start to get
more and more credibility of reach they
don't care about tarnishing anything if
it don't
exist yeah all right here we go James
Eaton says new Wuhan virus targets blood
bloodb brain barrier old covid tests
damaged it maybe plan all along was to
weaken people to catch new one easier
who knows but Chinese signed 100% kill
rate and is found in the brain that
being said there have been covid tests
that found similar things among mice so
who knows for
sure all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says
guys the future's sad the future is a
sad thought lonely guys pay for only
fans or AI girls and then there's the
girls doing only fans and face surgery
how will it all turn out in the future
the porn industry will cease to exist
women will no longer ever be able to do
porn yeah I believe it because AI I'm
sorry ladies men will be better at
making porn for men than women will be
of themselves yeah Dar what a loss to
society no porn will get worse than it's
ever been and it'll be worse than it's
ever been I think that's sort of what
you need for women to start being like
actually we don't like porn I feel like
right now if there's a chance they can
make money off it they're more open to
it if they stop being able to make money
off it been politicians doing porn with
their husbands on only fans in Virginia
and then when it was revealed they
claimed that they were victimized and
it's like girl you literally filmed
yourself having sex with your man and
put it on put it on there is a victimize
yourself there's an AI woman they have
videos she makes $30,000 a month I think
that's criminal and it should be listed
it should be fraud because guys think
it's a real woman and they're sending
money that should be fraud if it it
right okay if you're a man and you
create a fake profile with female
pictures trick men into giving you money
that is fraud you'll go to jail for that
this but these guys use Ai and they're
like it's totally cool we're using AI
it's like you should go to jail but the
language around these like AI generated
people like all the AI generated
influencers that exist there's a lot of
them now they start they they refer to
them like they are actual beings that
exist like there was the I don't
remember what it name is but uh it's a
female AI whatever she's an influencer
and then they're like she just released
a pop song but actually she didn't do
anything because she doesn't exist
people behind her did it and you use
someone else's voice you know what else
is gross are AI Fitness influencers yeah
oh yeah you haven't made any progress
you're just drawn different you're not
even real all right let's read some more
pup Shephard says I really like hell of
a boss when I learned of the plot of
hasbin Hotel I felt Deja Vu of stories
with childlike navite about people's
ability to change I don't like it hell
needs to be bad uh hell of a boss is
related I think it's the same animator
who's doing the show hasb been Hotel
Amazon bought it they have like millions
they have like a billion views on
YouTube it's really popular it's really
popular
uh I think it's funny seeing people say
it's propaganda and demonic that's why I
wanted to bring it up cuz I'm like
there's literally a show called Lucifer
where Lucifer is the good guy kind of
he's totally the good guy yeah yeah and
then you have he's also a little
depraved yeah yeah and that's that you
know and he solves murder mysteries
which is like just a weird
premise although I I really did like
when they did Crisis on infinite Earths
and Lucifer was in it and uh
Constantine's in it too and they did the
crossover I thought that was fun but
then there's also quite literally
Constantine where it's like he goes to
hell and you know he he like in the
movie canor Reeves actually confronts
the devil I'm not going to cry because
someone made fiction about religious
stuff or whatever but I do think there
is something interesting there in that
the first experience a young person may
have with religion will be through the
lens of poor Lucifer and poor Lilith and
then if someone actually comes him later
on and says like here's the religious
text they're going to be like that's BS
I watched that cartoon Lucifer was a
good guy hell was not bad and then it's
like actually if you watch the show I
was saying this too like they're all
really awful people like the characters
in hell yeah they're bad they're all bad
friends too I mean maybe friends was
just in hell they were terrible people
actually that's a that's a great premise
for a short film like the end of friends
it's just like they've in Hell the whole
time it turns out they're in hell it's
like s's no exit but it's just all the
friends characters that's actually that
would be really a fun watch I would
watch Li has a new project guys watch
this let's uh let's grab some more Super
chats what have we here man I'm fighting
Us in KN part of it too though is uh you
know we have stopped teaching our
children religion either in a faithful
way or an anthropological way so they're
not going to know these stories they're
not going to know anything about Lilith
or even who Adam and Eve are they're not
even going to understand the apple and I
think that's going to be the real
turning point for the um eradication of
Western literature when no one
understands the Bible no one's going to
understand Western lid anymore lith is
not in the Bible no no no I mean I I was
just looking it up and apparently
there's um apparently Isaiah says
something a Wilderness demon sh shunned
by Isaiah is something which I don't
remember personally but apparently
Lilith was uh according to biblical
archaeology.org her dark Origins lie in
Babylonian demonology they just make
Adam out to be like this dick you know
he's like you you know what's really
funny though I'd love to take that and I
you know here's what I'll do I will edit
that trailer and then it'll be like from
the dust of the earth they created Adam
and Lilith but Adam wanted her to submit
and she didn't want to so she fled the
garden where she died because she
couldn't survive on her own without a
man and that's how I'd end it I think
that would be good that would be at
least you know hueing to reality a
little more I agree what you're saying
though like they're they're not learning
like the bass stories like they talk
about art like you have to know like the
art in the past you change anything so
you know what you started from to go
forward and like with this they're not
going to know it yeah they're not even
they not even re aware of like oh they
may know the Paradigm hell is bad
Heaven's good but in this story it
doesn't seem like that at all no they
don't know it at all they won't know the
characters and I think part of
understanding literature When It Was
Written was also understanding cultural
influences like you need to be able to
teach Christianity without being like
well but it's evil so don't believe any
of this just the way you would need to
be able to teach any sort of philosophy
that maybe you don't personally believe
in but you're like here are what the
Illusions to these tenants might be and
I think that that uh knee-jerk reaction
to be like we can't talk about it
because it's ultimately bad is going to
starve really intellectually curious
younger Generations ultimately we got an
interesting one just leave me alone says
I watched Trump's speech in New
Hampshire no blisters photoshopped that
was in the article too it claimed that
later on when Trump was giving a speech
there were no blisters on his hands so
it's not that it's photoshopped Trump
may have literally just had red marker
on his hand yeah he's like sitting in a
meeting doodling and then they're like
you got to get that off your hand
immediately he's like okay or or he left
and went oh I got marker on my hand and
then they gave him a wash cloth and he
wiped it off and and now there's this
big story about him having syphilis cuz
he was like he's like drawing he's got
like a red marker and he's drawing a
picture of a cat you know or he's like
he's like actually a secret painter and
he just does it for himself and he was
using red paint and forgot to wash it
off here's a good one Mr grizzly bear
says I work for anheiser Bush on a
bottle line and there will absolutely be
a strike they are refusing to guarantee
guarantee job security and pay raises
and have left negotiations they want to
close down plants and we all know it
yeah cuz nobody's buying your beer dude
yo that's crazy that is crazy the
strikes will result in no product no
product means no sales their liabilities
are going to stack up and Heiser bush is
going to go that's it time to pull the
plug yeah shut him down I when the
boycotts were going on in the beginning
I felt sort of bad for the workers like
people who just work at the bottling
plants if if Bud Light LOF sales
potentially they're going to face layoff
right it's it's sort of in some ways
makes me feel better that this is a
strike that they are able to carry out
themselves it's like they have a choice
in the situation because they didn't
have a choice about the advertising
right if you're just a a factory worker
if you just work on the line you don't
get to say well actually don't think
it's a good idea to put Dylan mulvany in
this
ad all right let's grab some more so but
Donkey Kong says AMC theater's perfectly
popped popcorn it's so good well okay I
saw this great video you take the guy
took a straw and he stuck it into his
theater popcorn and then he pushed the
but the butter button and the butter
went into the straw into into the center
of the popcorn that's exactly what I do
there's a much better video where a
morbidly obese gentleman working at a
theater spins the popcorn around and
flips it in the air have you seen this
one no and they were like whatever it is
you do with your life be the best and
it's this like fat guy and he's like
spinning the popcorn and he throws in
the air catches it and then puts more
butter in spins it again and he's the
best popcorn guy I've ever seen so yeah
shout out that's cool it's like got
millions of views on his popcorn
spinning good check out this popcorn
Rabbit Hole yeah where is that seriously
where is that uh Google like popcorn
theater guy and you'll probably find it
cuz he has a bunch of videos apparently
where he's really good at making theater
popcorn I love people with Niche talents
he's like this this is what I am skilled
at and I'm going to do Christie popcorn
guy oh wow this blew up I think we
should go to Corpus Christie what's that
like maybe we should hire popcorn guy
for a party and like east of east of
Houston is South right it's like Coast
we should hire him for our uh ristan
opening party and we'll get like five
different kinds of popcorn and he can
mix them all together and like add stuff
to it this a great idea this is
fantastic I definitely we should do this
popcorn guy yeah I don't know what his
deal I don't think I saw his videos on
the internet popcorn guy Chris Corpus
Christie but you remember him like
that's the cool thing well I'm seeing a
news report on it so it's news people
talking I'm I haven't got to the video
yet sadly just jump ahead so you can see
it he didn't do this to become famous he
did this just cuz he loves popcorn he
was like I'm doing it with flare look at
him he spinning it on his finger oh yeah
he's the best look at basketball and
he's having a great
time we got to find this guy hire him
for a party anyone know this guy maybe s
tour was like a popcorn he's like now
going to other AMC Theaters and training
them but no one has he's hired by the
circus so when he's like if you want to
buy your popcorn it's part of the show
actually what if he grew up in the
circus and that's where the skill comes
from I I the lore is too much for me I
learned how to spin things on my finger
from working at nonprofits cuz when
you're standing outside with binder or a
clipboard the only thing you have to do
is just spin the binder on your finger
and now I can spin basically anything on
my face it's kind of crazy so this could
be you is what you're saying you're like
this close to becoming I'm actually
really imp impressed because the popcorn
is like like cylindrical it's like very
narrow I would not be able to spin that
well you start with the bucket and you
work your way to the narrow one I know
right that's very impressive you give me
like I could spin a pizza on my finger
like a pizza tray you give me like a
massive disc I can spin it over my head
basically indefinitely but something
narrow it's really difficult seems very
challenging yeah this is the thing like
people with Niche skills and interest
are just great he just did it because he
wanted to all right Dylan visitation
says my wife really likes appalachin
night's coffee and she never likes new
different things good job she also likes
Jeremy's razors for women seem like a
subtle dig here she never likes new
different things perhaps but I will say
uh when we were looking at the sales for
appach nights I was like holy crap we
sell like we sold out of the whole bean
like last week and wait to get more in
stock I think that's like our Star
product when when we first started we
were like rise with Roberto Jr it's got
a rooster on it everybody was buying
that and then I think what happens is
we're like yeah people like appoach kns
as well it's my personal
favorite meritocracy we can put a
rooster on the bag and people buy it for
that reason but when it comes down to
what what's the best and gets the most
sales people keep reing the Appalachian
Knight saying it's the best coffee
they've ever had I got I got to be
honest it is the best coffee I've ever
had yeah but I mean I made it for myself
it's like we get sent all these
different samples and Origins and I'm
like mixing them together and then I was
like oo this one's my favorite I want to
have this here are the flavors that I
like and uh it
worked all right rabert G stanberg JR
says Tim can I humbly request an
espresso blend I've been making Prime
Time grind and an espresso powder and
it's awesome wife likes a Mr Bokus
espresso that is good yeah we we uh the
plan is uh Ian's graphine dream is next
and then uh I I think after that we're
going to do um f with Mr bcus and
that'll be our espresso that's cool I
like that yeah although I I I am
surprised more people don't buy sleepy
Joe just because of the name of it it's
a cute name sleepy Joe yeah yeah making
fun of Joe Biden yeah there you go buy a
present for your family members I'd
rather buy the one that someone says is
the best coffee ever it it really is
crazy I mean it worked out for us we we
hit the nail on the head with that one
yeah appalachin Knights people tell us
all the time like they keep reing it
they're like I I man really excited that
people like it so much cuz it's my
favorite that's awesome all right Jean
Layman says Trump has flaming hot Cheeto
fingers could you imagine if that was
really it he's like sitting in the
courtroom munching on Flamin huts and
then he walks out waves wipes his hand
off it's gone and they're like he's got
syphilis it's a it's not a good
marketing pitch for flaming
Huts flaming Huts is G come out and be
like we do not we're not affiliated with
they used to call him the orange Cheeto
man so I mean it's kind of on it's kind
of Canon that would be the best product
like if after theous they're like he
becomes the spokesperson for like Trump
trump Cheetos yeah I would eat Trump I
like Cheetos BC asks why can't Biden
just Checkmate the Republicans by giving
amnesty to the millions who have
illegally entered the country he can
probably will at the end of the year Joe
Biden signs an executive order that's
what I keep saying is that's the plan
amnesty for all of these people before
he's out of office yes before he's out
of office you have Kathy hokel just
pledged 2.4 billion to make sure all the
illegal immigrants in New York get jobs
and shelter and whatever else mhm
imagine living in New York paying you
know $5,000 a month for your apartment
and now you have to pay taxes to fund
everybody else's free lifestyle yeah
this is this is wild to me Michael uh uh
Trot says I lived in San Antonio my
entire life the areas around the
Immigrant facility has changed crime has
definitely gone up the neighborhoods in
that area were pretty quiet now there's
illegals knocking on people's doors it's
kind of wild to me
that I'm imagining like France and
there's like a Village in you know I
don't know the 1400s or whatever and
then a bunch of British people start
just like running full speed into their
town and they're like oh look we're
being uh we're being enriched and then
there's like pillaging and fighting in
crime and they're just like I can't
believe this is happening what's
happened to our town like that that's
that's not how it would happen no this
is a total Invasion and it's people are
just standing there being like would you
look at that I the police they say
anti-immigration rhetoric is a problem
and that anti-immigration rhetoric and
and And discussing how you don't like
the government these are you know this
is part of the misinformation and
conspiracy theories no get the hell out
my town are there are uh red counties
all along the boorder of Texas that are
predominantly Hispanic and they got more
red under Trump they did they there is
people who legal IM immigrated who
settle down bu communicate no they don't
I mean can you imagine if it was like I
did everything by the book but if I had
it I would have actually gotten more
benefits in special treatment that seems
czy to me It ultimately undermines the
idea that we would reward people who
respect our government and our culture
enough to try and assimilate and follow
the rules it under people that live in
this country too like tanos chos that
have been here for before the United
States who were here in when it was part
of Spain and have been here in our
Americans and have and have just been
you know told like oh you're now an
illegal immigrant but in reality they've
been here longer than anyone has and
more than that it's the Democrats being
like well because of the color of skin
we think that you'll be sympathetic for
right right very true it's more of that
more of that uh low-key racism they got
going I feel like it's highkey I think
we should just call what it
is all right torum says the original
story is literally that Lilith was an
insane feminist got turned into a snake
for refusing to follow Adam's Direction
then God stole one of his ribs and made
Eve from it and said look now you aren't
equal obey
him huh yeah I I do think the story is
kind of funny cuz it's
like if if there was a man and a woman
in in the middle of the wilderness
on average if the guy was like hey we
have to do these things someone was like
no I'm not listening to you and ran off
she'd probably die yeah I think men and
women are complimentary and they should
work together and so I I think that's
okay right like I I don't think that
women should feel like partnering with a
man is a threat to them and I think
that's one of the problems with feminism
you know but but I view it kind of like
you are in a burning building and the
firefighter says do what I tell you and
you go no way and then you run upstairs
and then you die don't tell me what to
do man Guy The Narrative here about
Lilith in this show is that the guy is
just like I'm the boss as opposed to
being I am trying to save your life
listen to what I am telling you but you
know what to be honest you can bring a
horse to Harvard but you can't make him
learn yeah yeah it's funny like Lilith
was always to me is like the the he was
like the she's like the ex the crazy ex
of Adam right and so until God felt so
bad he was like here I'll make you a new
woman they I kind of screwed up with so
bad that's what I've always thought I
was so
the God shows up and he's like o what
happened like she was a feminist dude
like that's my bad let me try and help
you out there give you a tread wife she
was into abortions we can't have that in
the garden makes no sense yeah we the
first two people it's it's really bad
policy the idea abortion Lucifer was
attracted to her Fierce
Independence dude so I wonder that
fierce independ fierce Independence I
feel like that's the thing when guys are
like I just love that you're solo
maintenance it's like because then I
don't have to put any effort in you're
so independent like just then I never
have to call you or remember your
birthday like no don't have to ask you
out for Fridays no Dolph Ood says it is
not fiction Lilith is gnosticism it is
inherently satanic they aren't playing
with Christianity they are teaching
their actual religion yeah well there
you go those okay tatron says listen
every day read scnr regularly it gave me
the wisdom to kindly change my
girlfriend's mind on Trump she'll be
voting for him thanks to you
uh well uh it's actually thanks to you
all we can do is to the best of our
ability tell you the truth if you're
able to sort through it and discern what
is actually going on through the work we
are doing it's actually thanks to you
that you've convinced someone so you
know we can light the beacons but is you
who must tell everyone that they have
been lit so uh appreciate it and thanks
for for following the show yeah if she
submitted to you you do have to marry
her now that you just marry that
girl all right cam girl as soon says Tim
you know your idea to build culture
falls apart if the left can just amnesty
illegals to vote for them every so often
right how do you expect that problem to
be solved peacefully illegals will not
be swayed by culture who said the
solution to Illegal immigration will be
peaceful I believe that when Trump
enacts Mass deportations we would not
call the arrest of criminals peaceful
when a police officer serves a warrant
and kicks a dooran I wouldn't call it
peaceful but I would call it lawful
hopefully no one is hurt but
if you're a criminal who broke the law
to steal from this country and from the
other immigrants who are coming here
legally Then I then we are going to
remove you and it's very simple if law
enforcement comes to you and says sir
you are under arrest place your hands
behind your back well then it is a
peaceful arrest and much much of it will
be peaceful and then the people who
fight with cops refuse and their allies
uh and and various States who do will
make it not peaceful so there's that but
hopefully it will be uh peaceful in the
sense that they just go home all right
my friends if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net
show because these are very serious
topics you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
everywhere at Dom do you want to shout
anything out um not really just thanks
for having me
on right on what's your Twitter
_ L re right on thanks for hanging out
thank you thank you for having me it's
been fun having you here yeah it's been
a great time hopefully come back soon
yeah that' be cool uh I'm Hannah CL Remo
I'm a writer for cnr.com it's the best
you should definitely check out all our
work see stuff from Chris Bertman from
Chris Carr from Cassandra McDonald it's
great I love it there uh you can follow
their work at Tim cat it's @ timcast
news on uh X and Instagram if you want
to follow me I'm so bad at my outro
tonight uh if you want to follow me
personally I'm on X at hcbo and I'm on
Instagram at H.B thank you guys so much
Libby do a better job than I did I'm
Libby Emmons I'm the editor at the post
millennial you can follow our work at
the poost
millennial.age
and see everything that we're doing
thanks you did fine Hanah Clair that was
good uh think we had a good episode
today thanks for coming Dom appreciate
it pleasure uh and uh yeah I'm excited
to get to the after show I am surge.com
um still working on that URL I'll get it
soon enough uh see you guys soon we will
see you all over at timcast.net